Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. I announce this good news to the city. That Florence will be more glorious, richer, more powerful than she has ever been. First, glorious in the sight of God and of men. And you, oh Florence, will be the reformation of all Italy, and from here the renewal will begin and spread everywhere, for this is the naval of Italy, and your councils will reform all by the light and grace that God will give you.
感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们深受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我向全城宣布这个好消息。佛罗伦萨将变得比以往任何时候都更加辉煌、更加富裕、更加强大。首先，在上帝和世人眼中，它是辉煌的。而你，哦佛罗伦萨，将成为全意大利革新的中心，复兴将从这里开始并蔓延至各处，因为这是意大利的腹地，在上帝赐予你们的光芒和恩典下，你们的议会将革新一切。
Second, O Florence, you will have riches beyond number, and God will multiply all things for you. And third, you will spread your empire, and thus you will have power both temporal and spiritual, and you will have so many blessings that you will say, we want nothing more. But if you do not heed what I have told you, then you will have none of it. Then you will have none of it. Stirring stuff from the Dominican friar Gerolamo Savonarola, who was addressing the people of Florence on the 10th of December, 1492. And Dominic, he begins there sounding very much like a late 15th century preacher. And he ends up sounding a little bit like Donald Trump.
第二，哦佛罗伦萨，你们将拥有数不尽的财富，上帝将为你们使万物倍增。第三，你们将扩张帝国的版图，从而拥有世俗和精神的双重力量，你们将获得如此多的福祉，以至于你们会说，我们别无所求。但如果你们不听从我的忠告，那么你们将一无所有。你们将一无所有。这段激动人心的言论出自多明尼加修士吉罗拉莫·萨沃纳罗拉，他于1492年12月10日向佛罗伦萨人民发表了这番演讲。多米尼克，他一开始听起来非常像一个15世纪末的传教士。而到最后，他听起来有点像唐纳德·特朗普。
Everything's going to be great. You're going to have loads of money. Yeah, so much winning. So much winning. Bigly. Yeah. So much winning. So much winning. Bigly. Yeah. Right.
一切都会好起来的。你们会有用不完的钱。是的，赢得太多了。赢麻了。太棒了。是的。赢麻了。赢麻了。太棒了。是的。没错。
So, um, this is Savonarola's first appearance on the show and actually he sounds like a great man. You know, he's promising more power, more glory, more money, riches beyond number than people have ever known. Yeah. What's not to like? But anyone who knows anything about Savonarola will know that his prophecies of unlimited success were to end in scenes of fire and torture that even he with his powers of prediction could perhaps not have anticipated. So we're going to be looking
所以，嗯，这是萨沃纳罗拉在节目中首次亮相，实际上他听起来像个伟人。你知道，他承诺带来更大的权势、更多的荣耀、更多的金钱以及人们前所未见的数不尽的财富。是的，谁会不喜欢呢？但任何了解萨沃纳罗拉的人都知道，他对无限成功的预言最终将以烈火和酷刑收场，甚至连他这样具有预测能力的人恐怕也无法预料到这一点。所以我们今天要探讨的是
at Savonarola today, Tom. He's one of the most controversial characters, I think, in Renaissance history, in all Italian history. Some people see him as a saint, as a sort of early Protestant. Some people see him as a Catholic martyr. But do you know who has very strong opinion about Saffronarola? The historian Simon Seabag Montefiore. We both know. So he wrote a book called Monsters. Do you know what he said?
萨沃纳罗拉，汤姆。我认为他是文艺复兴历史、乃至整个意大利历史中最具争议的人物之一。有些人视他为圣人，类似于早期的抗议宗（新教）徒。有些人视他为天主教殉道者。但你知道谁对萨沃纳罗拉有极强的看法吗？历史学家西蒙·西巴格·蒙蒂菲奥里。我们俩都知道。因此，他写了一本名为《恶魔》的书。你知道他是怎么说的吗？
He said Saffronarola was one of the most evil men who ever lived He said he presided over an intolerant sanctimonious and murderous reign of terror his very name is a synonym for mad monks and the crimes of theocracy and Misguided virtue seems sounds great. Well, we're gonna find out whether that's actually true and a spoiler alert I think if the story is a little bit more complicated, it's really actually will amaze you to discover Tom. I'm a little bit team seven a roller. Yeah, that will amaze you. So you think John Lennon's a monster, but several are all as a saint.
他说，萨沃纳罗拉是有史以来最邪恶的人之一。他说他主持了一个不宽容、假惺惺且嗜血的恐怖统治，他的名字本身就是疯狂修士、神权政治罪行以及被误导的美德的代名词。听起来很棒。好吧，我们将探讨这是否属实，剧透一下，我认为故事其实要复杂得多，汤姆，你会惊讶地发现，我其实有点支持萨沃纳罗拉。是的，这会让你大吃一惊。所以你认为约翰·列农是个恶魔，但萨沃纳罗拉是个圣人。
Seven a roller never laid hands on a woman in anger. And that is the difference between him and John Lennon. ever laid hands on a woman in anger. And that is the difference between him and John Lennon. But anyway, I think the piquancy of Severnorello's story is that he's always contrasted with the man who precedes him. And that's the character who dominated our last episode. And that is the playboy head of the Medici family, Lorenzo the Magnificent. So Tom, you remember where we were last time?
萨沃纳罗拉从未在愤怒中对女人动过手。这就是他和约翰·列农的区别。从未在愤怒中对女人动过手。这就是他和约翰·列农的区别。不管怎样，我认为萨沃纳罗拉故事的妙处在于，他总是与他之前的那个人形成对比。而那个人正是上一集的主角。也就是美第奇家族的花花公子家主，“豪华者”洛伦佐。所以汤姆，你还记得我们上次讲到哪里了吗？
I do. We were in the dying weeks of 1479. We were in the dying weeks of 1479. We were. So people will remember that Lorenzo who's 29 years old has just survived an assassination attempt by the Pazzi conspirators at the high altar of Florence Cathedral, and this had triggered a war with Pope Sixtus the fourth and his ally, the king of Naples, King Ferrante. King Ferrante's son Alfonso has been fighting his
我记得。我们正处于1479年的最后几周。我们正处于1479年的最后几周。我们确实在那儿。所以大家会记得，29岁的洛伦佐刚刚在大教堂的高祭台前死里逃生，躲过了帕齐阴谋分子对他的暗杀，这引发了与教皇西克斯图斯四世及其盟友、那不勒斯国王费兰特国王的战争。费兰特国王的儿子阿方索一直在
way through Italy towards Florence and at the beginning of December 1479 Lorenzo made this dramatic decision. He wrote to the Signoria for Lawrence the council and he said, I've decided to sail for Naples immediately and put myself in our enemy's hands. So that's where we ended. Now what happens next? First of all, all the counselors apparently burst into tears, but they said, you know what, that's fair enough. This is probably the best way to save the Republic. Go for it. So the next day Lorenzo sails from the port of Vada and a few days
一路穿过意大利向佛罗伦萨推进，在1479年12月初，洛伦佐做出了这个戏剧性的决定。他写信给领主政府（Signoria），即佛罗伦萨议会，他说：“我决定立即启程前往那不勒斯，把自己交到敌人手里。”这就是我们上集结束的地方。那么接下来会发生什么？首先，所有的议员显然都放声大哭，但他们说，你知道吗，这倒也合情合理。这可能是拯救共和国的最佳方式。去吧！于是第二天，洛伦佐从瓦达港起航，在圣诞节前的几天
before Christmas he arrives in Naples. There King Ferrante's second son Federico is waiting to greet him on the sort of key side. And Dominic, would it be fair to say that like so many rulers in this story, Ferrante is a bit of a character? He is a character, Tom. So King Ferrante belongs to the House of Alagon, who have ruled in Naples for a couple of decades. He is your classic kind of Renaissance humanist, which is to say he loves a bit of Latin,
他抵达了那不勒斯。在那里，费兰特国王的次子费代里科正在码头上等候迎接他。多米尼克，这样说是否公平：就像这个故事中的许多统治者一样，费兰特也是个性情中人？他确实是个个性情中人，汤姆。费兰特国王属于阿拉贡家族，他们在过去几十年里统治着那不勒斯。他是那种典型的文艺复兴人文主义者，也就是说他非常喜欢拉丁文，
but also he is sallow, brooding, ruthless and vindictive. Nice. We are told by one account that he liked to have his critics and his opponents Latin, but also he is sallow, brooding, ruthless, and vindictive. Nice. We are told by one account that he liked to have his critics and his opponents always close at hand, preferably dead and embalmed. And I quote, dressed in the costume, which they wore in their lifetime. So what do you do? He'd have them killed and then have them stuffed or what would you do?
但同时他也是个面色阴郁、冷酷无情且记仇的人。不错。根据一份记载，他喜欢让批评者和反对者，拉丁文，但同时他也是个面色阴郁、冷酷无情且记仇的人。不错。根据一份记载，他喜欢让批评者和反对者随时待在触手可及的地方，最好是已经死去并被做成木乃伊。我引用一下：“穿着他们生前穿的衣服。”所以你会怎么做？他会把他们杀死，然后把他们做成标本，或者你会怎么做？
I don't know. I have, I haven't really looked into this, but I think you could easily. Let's imagine another another Goldhanger podcast Let's imagine Willie Dow Ripple You could have him killed have him embalmed and he could be with you right now when you're recording Would you not enjoy that? No, I wouldn't want to kill Willie. I think I'd find that inspirational, right? I think that's what's going on with King Franti. Okay as a thought it's a bit odd That's all I'm saying. Well Lorenzo actually gets on quite well with King Ferrante. He doesn't find this as unsettling as you do.
我不知道。我，我其实没怎么研究过这个，但我想你可以轻易做到。让我们想象另一个黄金衣架（Goldhanger）播客。让我们想象威利·道里普尔（Willie Dalrymple）。你可以把他杀了，做成木乃伊，当你录音时，他就可以一直陪着你。你难道不会觉得享受吗？不，我不想杀威利。我想我会觉得这很有启发性，对吧？我想费兰特国王就是这种心态。好吧，作为一个想法，这有点奇怪。我只想说这些。好吧，洛伦佐和费兰特国王其实相处得相当不错。他并不像你那样觉得这令人不安。
He's been in secret communication with the Neapolitan court. He knows that King Ferrante is a bit worried about tensions with France in particular. Now we'll come back to this in the next episode, which are brewing. They are brewing and he knows that the Neapolitans ultimately would like the war over. They also have a lot in common him and Ferrante, not the embalming, but they like poetry and music. Ferrante was one of the first Italians to import printing technology. He's got a massive library and they both love the classics like you. So this is something you would bond with them about. They love sitting around talking about Ovid or something.
他一直在与那不勒斯宫廷进行秘密通信。他知道费兰特国王对特别是与法国之间的紧张关系感到有些担忧。我们将在下一集中回过头来谈这一点，这种紧张局势正在酝酿中。它们正在酝酿，而他知道那不勒斯人最终希望战争结束。他和费兰特也有很多共同点，不是指做成木乃伊，而是他们都喜欢诗歌和音乐。费兰特是最早将印刷技术引入意大利的人之一。他拥有庞大的藏书，而且你们一样都热爱古典文学。所以这是你们会有共同语言的一个领域。他们喜欢坐在一起讨论奥维德之类的东西。
I'd enjoy doing that, but I just wouldn't want kind of dead stuffed people all around me. Right. OK, fair enough. That's all I'm saying. Just putting that on the record. Fair enough. Now, actually, Lorenzo cuts a great dash. She spends a lot of money. He buys the freedom when he arrives of the galley slaves on the ship. They make a show of doing this. So basically just being a magnificent.
我很乐意这么做，但我只是不想周围都是死去的塞满填充物的人。好吧，公平地说。我只想说这些。只是把它记录在案。好吧。事实上，洛伦佐气宇轩昂，风度翩翩。他花了很多钱。他一到就买下了船上苦力的自由。他们大张旗鼓地这样做。所以基本上就是表现得极其阔绰。
Yeah. What a tremendous fellow. He gives those money to poor neoporlots and girls. But actually, and this is an important theme of this episode, he is paying for the trip by mortgaging his country estate in the Mugello for 60,000 Florians. So his act, his magnificence, well, it is just an act. It's just performative. It's smoke and mirrors. And this is going to run through this story. Anyway, it works. He gets a deal, not a terribly good deal, I have to say. He has to give up a bit of territory and Florence has to pay a big indemnity. But he goes back to Florence in the following March. A great hero. There are kind of balls and fireworks, bells ringing.
是的。真是个了不起的家伙。他把钱分给那不勒斯的贫苦女孩。但实际上，这也是本集的一个重要主题，他是通过把自己在穆杰罗的乡村庄园抵押了6万弗罗林来支付这次旅行的费用的。所以他的举动，他的阔绰，其实只是一场表演。这只是一场作秀。不过是烟幕弹。这贯穿了整个故事。无论如何，这招奏效了。他达成了一项协议，虽然不得不说这并不是一笔多好的交易。他不得不放弃了一点领土，佛罗伦萨还得支付一大笔赔偿金。但他第二年三月回到了佛罗伦萨。成了一个大英雄。到处都是舞会、烟花和敲钟。
And he tosses out sweetmeats, doesn't he? This seems to be a big thing. Yeah. He's always tossing out sweetmeats. Exactly. And that at his slightly camp, hey, nonny, nonny, and away. Yeah. So now he's come back to Florence and he's the hero of the hour and he seizes his opportunity. So until now, Lorenzo has acted very much like his grandfather, Cosimo, of whom you know, I'm a big fan. He has hidden his power beyond a kind of pretence of constitutionalism,
他还会抛撒糖果，对吧？这似乎是一件大事。是的。他总是到处抛撒糖果。没错。还有他那种略带滑稽的、载歌载舞的欢快作风。是的。现在他回到了佛罗伦萨，成为了当下的英雄，他抓住了机会。所以在此之前，洛伦佐的表现非常像他的祖父科西莫——你知道我是科西莫的超级粉丝。他将自己的权力隐藏在一种宪政主义的伪装之下，
very much like Augustus. But now he thinks, you know, Florence is slightly up against it financially and I can't take any chances. And he calls an emergency assembly and he sets up a new council called the Council of 70 that gives him basically the power to veto any legislation he doesn't like. It gives him control of France's foreign policy. And it basically means that now every single appointment to office, Lorenzo has to approve. And the council of 70, it's a very sinister sounding institution.
非常像奥古斯都。但现在他认为，你知道，佛罗伦萨在财务上有点捉襟见肘，我不能冒任何险。于是他召集了一次紧急会议，并成立了一个名为“七十人议会”的新委员会，这基本上赋予了他否决任何他不喜欢立法的权力。这赋予了他对法国外交政策的控制权。这意味着现在每一个官职的任命，基本上都必须得到洛伦佐的批准。而这个七十人议会，是一个听起来非常阴险的机构。
The kind of thing that would feature in a Jacobean tragedy. Exactly. Exactly. So Lorenzo now something has changed. He sort of still says, oh, I'm just the private citizen, you know, he doesn't hold any office. But in official documents, he is called the first man, the foremost man in the state. And there's a couple of very telling signs of this. So number one, actually, he's the only man in Florence allowed to carry weapons.
这种东西往往会出现在詹姆士一世时期的悲剧里。没错。没错。所以现在洛伦佐有些东西变了。他某种程度上仍然宣称：“噢，我只是个普通公民，你知道的，”他没有担任任何公职。但在官方文件中，他被称为“第一人”，即国家中最显赫的人。有几个非常说明问题的迹象。首先，事实上，他是佛罗伦萨唯一被允许携带武器的人。
And he goes around now with a personal bodyguard of armed mercenaries. And they actually sound like a splendid crew. There's black Martin, there's Morgana, the giant, and there's also a man who's just called mutant. So they sound great from very kind of superhero. Yeah. But also very tellingly in the Palazzo della Signoria, there had always been sort of busts and stuff of great Roman Republican heroes. But now they are accompanied by kind of roundel portraits of Roman emperors. And I think that's indicative of a shift that the political culture has changed from one
他现在出行都有由武装雇佣兵组成的私人保镖随行。他们听起来确实是一支华丽的队伍。有“黑马丁”，有巨人“摩尔根”，还有一个绰号叫“变种人”的家伙。所以他们听起来很棒，非常有超级英雄的感觉。是的。但同样非常说明问题的是，在领主宫（Palazzo della Signoria）里，一直都有伟大的罗马共和国英雄们的半身像之类的东西。但现在它们旁边还配有罗马皇帝的圆形肖像画。我认为这表明了一种政治文化上的转变：
that's very much identified itself with the Roman Republic to one in which the Medici are now thinking of themselves as akin to, you know, the Julio-Claudians or something. And isn't Cicero, who had been a great hero of the Republic, kind of rebranded as the man who had foiled the conspiracy of Catiline in the way that Lorenzo had foiled the conspiracy of the Pazzi? That's exactly right. I'm just wondering, I mean, this is exactly the kind of thing that Augustus does in his great temple of Mars, where he counterpoints people from his own family, the Julians, with the Republican heroes.
从一个强烈认同罗马共和国的文化，转变为美第奇家族开始将自己视为类似于朱利奥-克劳狄王朝之流的文化。难道西塞罗——曾经是共和国的伟大英雄——不是被重新包装成了挫败卡提利纳阴谋的人，就像洛伦佐挫败帕齐阴谋那样吗？完全正确。我只是在想，我的意思是，这正是奥古斯都在他的伟大战神庙中所做的那种事，他将自己家族（尤利乌斯家族）的人与共和国英雄们进行对比。
That's interesting. Which I assume Lorenzo is aware of. And in one sense, he's kind of probably copying it because Augustus had done it. But of course, in another sense, he is learning from ancient history, isn't he? Yeah, he is. And that idea that classical history provides lessons from which people in Renaissance Italy can profit is one that will be most famously exemplified in the writings of Machiavelli, a Florentine, who at this
这很有趣。我猜洛伦佐是意识到这一点的。从某种意义上说，他可能在效仿它，因为奥古斯都是这么做的。但当然，从另一个意义上说，他正在向古代历史学习，不是吗？是的，他是。古典历史为文艺复兴时期的意大利人提供了可以从中受益的教训，这种观点将在佛罗伦萨人马基雅维利的著作中得到最著名的体现，我认为此时他正接近少年时期。是的，他这个阶段还是个孩子。所以正处于极易受影响的年龄，目睹这一切。这一定对他产生了相当大的影响。我认为你绝对说得对。我认为马基雅维利，是的，他无疑深深沉浸在那种文化中。关于洛伦佐和奥古斯都，我要说的唯一一点是，奥古斯都，当然，正如你对苏埃托尼乌斯的翻译中所知，汤姆，我顺便为你做了一个不错的广告。
point I think is just approaching his teens. Yes, his child at this stage. So a very impressionable age watching this. It must have had quite an impact on him. I think you're absolutely right. I think Machiavelli, yeah, he's steeped in that culture, undoubtedly. The one thing I'd say about Lorenzo and Augustus, Augustus, of course, we know from your translation of Suetonius, Tom, nice bit of advertising there I've done for you.
谢谢。奥古斯都投射出的形象，不是吗，是一种谦逊。是的。你知道的，他吃干酪，穿便服之类的。而洛伦佐则不然。洛伦佐投射出的是一种阔绰宏大的形象。我认为这绝对是一个区别，它反映了15th世纪意大利的那种王公贵族文化。
Cheers. Augustus projected an image, didn't he, of modesty. Yes. You know, he eats his cheese, plain clothes and all that kind of thing. Now Lorenzo does not. Lorenzo projects an image of magnificence. And I think that definitely is a difference and that reflects the kind of princely culture of 15th century Italy.
我们稍后在谈论艺术时会回到这一点。我必须说，洛伦佐的佛罗伦萨也有黑暗的一面，比如他身边跟着一个叫“变种人”的家伙，还扛着一个很大的标志，是吗？是的。所以每隔几年，就会有刺杀他的阴谋被揭发。而我们无法判断这些阴谋是真实的还是想象出来的。基本上，如果你在其中某个阴谋中站错了边，你知道的，报复是相当残酷的。所以有一个记载，讲的是1480年有一个隐士被指控
And we'll come back to that in a second when we talk about art. There is, I have to say a dark side to Lorenzo's Florence and the fact that he's accompanied by a man called mutant carrying a very large sign, is it? Yeah. So every few years there are plots uncovered to assassinate him. And we can't tell whether these plots are real or imagined. And basically if you're on the wrong side of one of these plots, you know, the vengeance is pretty brutal. So there's an account of a hermit in 1480 who was accused
想要暗杀洛伦佐。人们说他的脚底板被剥了皮，然后被架在火上，在圆木上烤，直到油脂流出。接着他们让他站起来，强迫他走过粗糙的粗盐，直到他因此死去。我的天，想象一下那种难以忍受的痛苦。但这里最关键的一句是：“他究竟有没有罪，从未真正确立。有人说有，有人说没有。”所以对我们这个时代的人来说，不可能知道这究竟是在算账，
of wanting to assassinate Lorenzo. Men said the souls were stripped from his feet, which were then put over the fire and held over the logs until the fat ran. Then they stood him up and made him walk over coarse crusted salt so that he died of this. I mean, imagine the excruciating agony. But here's the crucial line. It was never really established whether he had sinned or not. Some said yes, and some said no. So it's impossible for us at this distance to know whether this is score settling,
还是在杀鸡儆猴，又或者是否真的存在阴谋。你知道的，这种相当压抑的政权本质是什么？能想出那种酷刑的人。没错。文艺复兴时期的佛罗伦萨有一种有时被忽视的虐待狂倾向。正如克里斯托弗·希伯特在他那本关于这一时期的欢快通俗历史中所说的那样，大多数佛罗伦萨人显然并不真正在乎。他们有食物，有令人兴奋的公共节日，
whether this is making an example of somebody, whether there really had been a conspiracy. You know, what's the nature of this sort of quite repressive regime? Imagine thinking up that, that kind of torture. Exactly. There is a sort of a sadism to Renaissance Florence that I think is sometimes lost. As Christopher Hibbett says in his sort of very jolly popular history this period, most Florentines obviously didn't really care. They had food, they had exciting public holidays,
而且他们有正义。所以，面包和马戏。他们有令人兴奋的公共节日，并且他们有正义。所以，面包和马戏。面包和马戏。现在他们仍然有敌人。教皇西克斯图斯四世痛恨美第奇家族，但实际上洛伦佐在他的整个职业生涯中都很幸运，因为佛罗伦萨发生的事情往往受到其他地方更大权力事件的影响。所以在1480年，奥斯曼人登陆了意大利南部，
and they had justice. So bread and circuses., they had exciting public holidays and they had justice. So bread and circuses. Bread and circuses. Now they still had enemies. The Pope, six to the fourth, he loathes Medici, but actually Lorenzo is lucky throughout his career because so often what's happening in Florence is affected by what's happening elsewhere with actually bigger powers. So in 1480, the Ottomans landed in the south of Italy,
在奥特朗托，整个意大利陷入了恐慌。每个人都认为，天哪，仍在君士坦丁堡掌权的征服者穆罕默德，要把那不勒斯和罗马并入君士坦丁堡了。我的意思是，这并非不可信，对吧？他完全有可能做到这一点。确实可能。而且还要说的是，在奥特朗托的暴行，
at Otranto, and there was panic across Italy. Everybody thought, my God, Mehmet the Conqueror, who's still in charge in Constantinople, he's gonna add Naples and Rome to Constantinople. I mean, it's not implausible, right? It's perfectly possible he could do that. It's not. And also just to say that the atrocities in Otranto,
无论是否被夸大，这些报道都非常非常令人担忧，因为大主教在自己的祭坛前被杀。大教堂里发生了大量亵渎行为，大教堂被改成了清真寺。据说奥特朗托有800人殉道。正如我们将在本集和下一集所看到的，这助长了一种弥漫末日恐慌的庞大情绪。关于世界末日的预言已经在四处流传，土耳其人征服意大利的前景绝对是其中的核心内容。
whether they're amplified or not, but the reports are very, very alarming because the archbishop gets killed in front of his own altar. There's lots of soaring in the cathedral, which gets turned into a mosque. And it said that 800 people of Otranto are martyred. And this, as we will see over the course of this episode in the next, feeds into a massive mood of apocalyptic panic. Kind of prophecies of the end of the world were already swirling around in which the prospect of the Turks conquering Italy is an absolute staple.
全乱套了。是的，你说得完全对。与此同时，这种挥之不去的焦虑感一直存在，关于奥斯曼帝国的推进以及关于世界末日。如果不把这一点记在心里，发生的许多事情就说不通。无论如何，基本上因为这一点，教皇说，好吧，没关系，我们应该，我们应该和佛罗伦萨言归于好。有一个滑稽的场面，佛罗伦萨使节去了罗马。他们道歉，但声音非常含糊不清，以至于没人能听见。然后教皇接受了他们的
It's all kicking off. Yeah, you're dead right. All this time, there is this sort of looming anxiety about the Ottoman advance and about the end of the world. And a lot of what happens won't make sense unless people keep that at the back of their minds. Anyway, basically because of this, the Pope says, okay, fine, we're supposed to, we should make up with Florence. There's a sort of comical scene where Florentine envoys go to Rome. They apologize, but very inaudibly so nobody can hear them. And then the Pope accepts their
道歉，但他也含糊其辞地嘟囔着，同样没人能听清，因为他们双方都被对彼此的厌恶吞噬了。于是他解除了对佛罗伦萨的所有禁令之类的事情。洛伦佐派了一些桨帆船去协助对抗奥斯曼人。但实际上，又来了一次好运，征服者穆罕默德在1481年去世了，所以奥斯曼人基本上都回家去处理一场小型的王位继承危机了，意大利安全了。接着，洛伦佐又迎来了一次天大的好运。他又开始和教皇吵架了，但随后教皇却意外驾崩了。佛罗伦萨人一点也不难过。佛罗伦萨驻罗马使节给洛伦佐写信道：“今天五点钟，教皇西克斯图斯四世魂归西天。愿上帝原谅他。”他的继任者是一个叫英诺森八世的人。现在，对文艺复兴时期教皇制度持负面看法的人不会感到意外地听说，英诺森八世已经有了七个孩子。所以并不是那么“英诺森”（纯洁无辜）。
apology, but he also mutters it so no one can hear it because they're both so eaten up with mutual loathing. So he lifts all the sort of the interdict and stuff that he'd had on Florence. Lorenzo sends some galleys to help against the Ottomans. But actually, now another stroke of luck, Mehmet the Conqueror dies in 1481, so the Ottomans basically all go home to have a little succession crisis and Italy is safe. And then another great stroke of luck for Lorenzo. He's gone back to squabbling with the Pope, but then the Pope drops dead unexpectedly. The Florentines are not sorry at all. The Florentine envoy in Rome writes to Lorenzo, today at five o'clock is holiness, six just
并非那么纯洁无辜，其中两个他不知怎么还设法让其合法化了。但每个人都说他其实是个不错的人。他非常世俗，随和。洛伦佐基本上通过送他一车美酒和华丽布料赢得了他的好感。所以英诺森非常喜欢这一切。他高兴极了。因此，洛伦佐得以取得两项重大外交成功。首先，他将女儿玛德莱娜嫁给了教皇的儿子弗朗切斯科托。我的意思是，这太棒了，对吧？这是一件值得夸耀的事。是的。
the fourth departed his life. May God forgive him. And his successor is a guy called Innocent the Eighth. Now people who have a low view of the Renaissance papacy will be unsurprised to hear that Innocent the Eighth already had seven children. So not so innocent. Not so innocent, two of which he'd somehow managed to legitimize. But he's a very, everyone says he's actually not a bad guy. He's very worldly, he's kind of easy going. Lorenzo is able to basically win him over by sending him a
我竟然把教皇不该存在的儿子娶进了门。而且，我提到了克里斯托弗·希伯特。他总是擅长写人物小传。克里斯托弗·希伯特。他说，玛德莱娜是一个相貌平平、五官犀利的16岁女孩，而弗朗切斯科托快40岁了，是一个发福、无趣的男人，据说一生中从未说过一句有趣的话。听起来这真是一桩美满的婚姻。
load of wine and fancy cloth. So innocent loves all this. He's delighted. And as a result, Lorenzo is able to score two big diplomatic successes. First of all, he marries his daughter, Madeleina to the Pope's son, Franceschetto. I mean, that's amazing, isn't it? That's something to boast about. Yeah.
然后另一件事，洛伦佐——如果托马斯·克伦威尔在听的话，他一定会爱死这个——洛伦佐说服教皇册封他的次子乔瓦尼为枢机主教（红衣主教）。作为回报，他借给教皇十万杜卡特，这是一笔巨款。乔瓦尼当时只有13岁，但教皇说，好吧，听起来不错。我相信这会很棒。于是他册封他为枢机主教，但规定他只有到了16岁才能穿上那套红衣法袍。这可是件值得期待的事，对吧？
I've, I've married the Pope's son who shouldn't exist. And, uh, I mentioned Christopher Hibbett. He's always very good at the pen portraits. Christopher Hibbett. He said, uh, Madelaine was a plain sharp featured girl of 16 and Franceschetto almost 40, a portly boring man, reputed never to have made a single interesting remark in his life. So that sounds like a brilliant marriage.
是的。哪个13岁的孩子不梦想穿上那顶红衣主教的帽子呢？谁不梦想这个呢？一件红袍。是的。所以很高兴看到15世纪末的天主教会依然保持着标准。是的。
And then the other thing, Lorenzo, again, this is if Thomas Cromwell is listening, he'll be loving this. Lorenzo persuades the Pope to name his second son Giovanni a Cardinal. And in return, he lends him a hundred thousand ducats, which is a massive sum. Giovanni is only 13 years old, but the Pope says, yeah, he sounds great. I'm sure it will be brilliant. And he names him a Cardinal, but he's only allowed to put on the gear when he turns 16. That's something to look forward to, isn't it?
所以你看，因为枢机主教是教会的亲王，不是吗？洛伦佐可以说，好吧，我们的地位与意大利的诸侯们并驾齐驱。这当然是科西莫做梦也没想到的事。科西莫的梦想基本上只是堆积金钱，但洛伦佐确实把自己想象成理想的文艺复兴亲王。这就是至今仍流传于世的形象。你知道吗？如果说这一切全都是骗局和伪造，未免有些诱人，但洛伦佐在某些方面的确配得上这种形象。
Yeah, it is. What 13 year old doesn't dream of putting on that Cardinal's hat? He doesn't dream of that. A red robe. Yeah. So it's good to see that there are still standards in the Catholic church in the late 15th century. Yeah.
我的意思是，当他去乡间时，他的确周围环绕着各种知识分子、作家、哲学家之类的人。正如西塞罗曾经做过的那样。没错。他有一个叫安杰洛·波利齐亚诺的家伙，他是15th世纪、15th世纪佛罗伦萨顶尖的学者之一。他是洛伦佐最亲密的朋友之一。
So now you see, cause the Cardinals are Prince of the church, isn't it? Lorenzo can say, well, we rank alongside the princes of Italy. Now this is of course something that Cosimo had not really dreamed of. Cosimo had just dreamed of basically piling up money, But Lorenzo really does fancy himself as the ideal Renaissance Prince. And that's the image that endures today. And you know what? It would be tempting to say it's all a complete con and a fraud, but Lorenzo clearly does deserve that image in some ways.
另一个非常亲密的朋友是一位名叫皮科·德拉·米兰多拉的哲学家。他写了一本书叫《关于人类尊严的演讲》，常被称为伟大的文艺复兴宣言。他就像路德一样，对吧？酷爱命题。酷爱命题。我想他发表了，是900条命题还是什么的？是的。
I mean, when he goes to the country, he does surround himself with kind of intellectuals and writers and philosophers and things. As Cicero had done. Exactly. He has this bloke called Angelo Poliziano, who's one of the top scholars of the 15th century, 15th century Florence. He's one of his closest friends.
900条命题。数量惊人。基本上他说，我可以把所有的知识浓缩为900条命题。事实上他说，你知道吗？所有人类的知识，所有的哲学，都在趋向于一个单一的统一真理。这可以是犹太教的卡巴拉，也可以是阿拉伯的东西。它可以是万物，把它们全放在一起，它们基本上都指向同一个地方。
Another really close friend is a philosopher called Pico della Mirandola. He wrote a book called The Oration on the Dignity of Man, which is often described as the kind of great Renaissance manifesto. And he's like Luther, isn't he? That he loves a thesis. Loves a thesis. I think he publishes, is it 900 theses or something? Yeah.
非常适合每日箴言（Thought for the day）。是的，没错。这非常具有普世性。是的。归根结底，我们都是，你知道的，我们都是人类。我们都是上帝的孩子。是的。我们都是上帝的孩子。
900 theses. Enormous number. And basically he said, I can reduce all knowledge to 900 theses. And actually he said, do you know what? All human knowledge, all philosophy is tending towards a single unified truth. That could be Jewish, the Kabbalah, it could be Arabic stuff. It could be everything like put it all together and it all basically goes towards the same place.
现在，许多人听到这里会说，这太美妙了。但当时，许多人却认为这简直是精神错乱。这太疯狂了。所以他相当有争议。无论如何，有这些人在，有音乐家，有诗人。现在洛伦佐自己也写诗。我知道塔比（Tabby）是洛伦佐诗歌的超级粉丝。她说我们一定要提到这一点。所以他用托斯卡纳方言写作，而不是拉丁文。
Very thought for the day. Yes, exactly. It's very ecumenical. Yeah. Ultimately we're all, you know, we're all human. We're all God's children. Yeah. We're all God's children.
就像但丁和薄伽丘做的那样。所以他是但丁和薄伽丘的粉丝。这某种程度上也是促使托斯卡纳方言演变为意大利语的原因，对吧？成为占主导地位的意大利语。没错。我想你可能会喜欢读一些他的诗，汤姆。我为你挑选了两个例子。谢谢。其中一个是由英国桂冠诗人特德·休斯在20世纪90年代翻译的。你想读一些他的诗吗，汤姆？我为你挑选了两个例子。谢谢。其中一个是由英国桂冠诗人特德·休斯在20世纪90年代翻译的。你想朗读这首我认为相当感人的诗吗？
Now, a lot of people listen to this now and say, that's lovely. But actually at the time, a lot of people say that's demented. That's mad. So he's quite controversial. Anyway, there are these guys, there are musicians, there are poets. Now Lorenzo writes his own poetry. I know Tabby's a big fan of Lorenzo's poetry. She said we should definitely mention it. So he writes in Tuscan, not Latin.
我们所有的希望都是徒劳，我们所有的设计都是虚幻，我们用无知填满这个世界。我们从我们的导师——坟墓那里汲取教训。所以我觉得这相当深奥，但我认为这一首没那么深奥。这首叫《农民之歌》。这是特德·休斯翻译的吗？不是，你可以用你选择的任何口音来读。
So like Dante had done and Boccaccio. So he's a fan of Dante and Boccaccio. And this is kind of part of what will make Tuscan become Italian, right? Become the dominant Italian. Exactly. Now I thought you might like to read some of his poetry, Tom. I've chosen two examples for you. Thank you. Now one was translated by Britain's poet laureate Ted Hughes in the 1990s. Would you like to read some of his poetry, Tom. I've chosen two examples for you. Thank you. Now one was translated by Britain's poet laureate, Ted Hughes in the 1990s. Would you like to read this poem, which I think is quite moving?
我可以用那种载歌载舞的滑稽腔调来读吗？读吧！我们都有黄瓜，而且个头很大。它们在你看来可能又老又疙瘩，但它们非常适合疏通堵塞的管道。用双手去采摘它们，然后剥开顶部，扒开皮，张大嘴巴把它们吸进去。所以这稍微带点黄色笑话的成分。我认为这样说很公平。海滨游乐场的趣味。
Our futile every hope is that we have our illusory all our designs and our cram this world with ignorance. We learn from our master. Grave. So I think that's quite profound, but I think this one is a little bit less profound. This is called the Song of the Peasants. Is this translated by Ted Hughes? No, you can do whatever accent you choose.
是的，海滨明信片式的趣味。全都是关于那些又大又疙瘩的黄瓜。太棒了。是的。然而，尽管我们可能会笑，我当时在想把他和我们的顶级政治家、文艺复兴亲王、文艺复兴人基尔·斯塔默作个对比。基尔·斯塔默接受了《卫报》的采访，他们顶级政治家、文艺复兴亲王、文艺复兴人基尔·斯塔默。基尔·斯塔默接受了《卫报》的采访，他们问他，你最喜欢的
Can I do it in a hey nonny nonny way? Do! We've all got cucumbers and big ones too. They may look old and knobbly to you, but they're great for opening up pipes that are closed. Use both hands to pluck them, then expose the top, peeling back the skin, open wide your mouths and suck them in. So this is the slightly more bawdy side. I think it's fair to say. Seaside fun.
书是什么？他说，嗯，其实我没有最喜欢的书。他什么最喜欢的也没有。他没有任何文化兴趣可言。洛伦佐回答这个问题绝对毫不费劲，因为他在美第奇图书馆上花了巨资。他派特工前往奥斯曼帝国，带回了200本希腊书籍，其中许多在此之前完全不为人知。
Yeah, seaside postcard fun. All this stuff about big knobbly cucumbers. Brilliant. Yeah. However, much as we might laugh, I was thinking about comparing him with our top statesman. Renaissance Prince. Renaissance man, Keir Starmer. Keir Starmer was interviewed by The Guardian and they top statesman, Renaissance Prince, Renaissance man, Keir Starmer. Keir Starmer was interviewed by the Guardian and they said to him, what's your favorite
但我的意思是，为了支持基尔·斯塔默说句话，他可没有把隐士的脚架在火上烤，然后强迫他们在盐上走路。所以有得必有失。我猜是这样。但我认为，为了拥有一位爱书成痴的首相，付出这个代价是值得的。是吗？是的。另外，你看，洛伦佐捐了大量
book? And he said, well, I don't have a favorite book actually. And he didn't have a favorite anything. He had no cultural interests whatsoever. Lorenzo would have had no trouble answering that question because he spent tons of money on the Medici library. He sent agents to the Ottoman Empire and they brought back 200 Greek books, many of which had been completely unknown.
资金给大学、人文学系，而事实上英国的人文学系正处于危机之中。是的，我们赞同这一点。它们陷入危机是因为威斯敏斯特数十年的庸俗无知（Philistinism）。另一件事实际上是，你和洛伦佐有这个共同点，但我相信基尔·斯塔默没有。洛伦佐是一位热情的艺术和珍玩收藏家，引述：“青铜器、奖章、硬币、古代陶器、古董宝石以及罗马、拜占庭、波斯和威尼斯花瓶。”这非常像你。你很喜欢威尼斯花瓶，对吧？我是。是的，我真的很喜欢。我现在很纠结。
But I mean, just to stick up for Kirsten, he's not roasting the feet of hermits over fires and then making them walk on salt. No. So you win some, you lose some. I guess. But I think that would be a price worth paying to have a bibliophile prime minister. Would you? I would. Also, you see, Lorenzo gave a lot
是的，我知道。这很难，对吧？我不知道我是否希望“豪华者”洛伦佐当首相。是的。我的意思是，他确实把佛罗伦萨人的钱全挥霍光了，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个问题。他确实这么做了。我们马上就会谈到这一点。所以他作为伟大的文艺复兴赞助人被世人铭记。
of money to universities, to humanities departments, and actually the humanities are in crisis in Britain. Yeah, we approve of that. They're in crisis because of decades of Philistinism in Westminster. The other thing actually, so you've got this in common with Lorenzo, but not, I believe, with Kirzdama. Lorenzo is a passionate collector of art and curios, quote bronzes, medals, coins, ancient pottery, antique gems and Roman Byzantine Persian and Venetian vases. So that's very much like you. You love the Venetian vase, don't you? I do. Yeah, I really do. I'm torn now.
你知道吗？这是不对的，因为实际上他委托创作的艺术品比他的祖父科西莫少得多，也比他那位名字容易让人混淆的堂弟洛伦佐少得多。所以基本上当你去佛罗伦萨，然后说，“哦，这是美第奇家族的洛伦佐的藏品，”往往搞错了人。通常是另一个洛伦佐，因为这个另一个洛伦佐才是委托创作波提切利的《春》和《维纳斯的诞生》（波提切利最著名的作品）的人，而不是“豪华者”洛伦佐。
Yeah, I know. It's difficult, isn't it? I don't know whether I want Lorenzo the Magnificent to be prime minister or not. Yeah. I mean, he does blow all the Florentines money, right? I mean, that's one issue. He does. We're going to come onto this. So he's remembered as the great Renaissance patron.
但他擅长的是，他将艺术作为佛罗伦萨软实力的一部分。基本上他做到这一点的方式是将他的艺术家“推销”给其他文艺复兴时期的君主。所以他派波提切利和一个叫多梅尼科·吉兰达约的家伙去绘制西斯廷教堂，在与教皇言归于好之后。而且，平心而论，他是个伯乐，因为他鼓励了下一代艺术家，包括可以说是所有名字中最大的两个。其中一个是来自托斯卡纳乡村的私生子，曾师从洛伦佐的另一个最爱韦罗基奥当学徒，最终在美第奇宫殿住了
And you know what? That is wrong, because actually he commissioned much less art than his grandfather Cosimo and much less art than his cousin who's confusingly called Lorenzo. So basically when you go to Florence and you say, oh, this belonged to Lorenzo de' Medici, it's the wrong one. It's usually the other one because this other Lorenzo is the bloke who commissioned Botticelli's Primavera and his Birth of Venus, Botticelli's most famous works, not Lorenzo the Magnificent.
一段时间，然后才前往米兰。这个人就是列奥纳多·达·芬奇。另一个人也来自托斯卡纳乡村，同样师从美第奇的另一个最爱吉兰达约。1488年，洛伦佐对吉兰达约说：“我要创办一所新的艺术学校，因为你推荐了有才华、有前途的年轻学生。”吉兰达约说，“噢，这家伙太棒了。”他的名字叫米开朗基罗。
But what he is good at, he uses art as part of Florence's soft power. And basically the way he does that is by pimping out his artists to other Renaissance monarchs. So he sends Botticelli and a guy called Domenico Ghirlandaio to do the Sistine Chapel after he's made up with the Pope. And it's a talent spotter, to be fair, because he encourages the next generation of artists, including arguably the two biggest names of all. So one of them is an illegitimate boy from Tuscany, from rural Tuscany, who was apprenticed to another Lorenzo favorite, Verrocchio, and ended up living in the Medici Palace for
你知道吗，多米尼克，我觉得如果你是那个发掘了列奥纳多和米开朗基罗的人，我觉得你完全可以自称为文艺复兴艺术的伟大赞助人。是的，我觉得这很公平。你不这么认为吗？我想是的。也许你没有直接委托创作作品，但你确实在甄别和发掘人才，就像球探一样。是的。就像纽卡斯尔联队的球探发掘了阿兰·希勒那样的人。我更倾向于那种在60年代深入俱乐部发掘披头士乐队或滚石乐队的经纪人。好吧，公平地说。布莱恩·爱泼斯坦。是的。每当遇到不确定的情况，你就会搬出披头士，我也提到了滚石乐队。是的，你提到了。不管怎样，你可以理解为什么外国宫廷认为洛伦佐是一个值得尊重的同辈。基本上，他们把他看作和他们自己一样的人。他不仅仅是个商人。他不仅仅是个银行家。他超越了科西莫所做的一切。
a time before going off to Milan. And this was somebody called Leonardo da Vinci. And the other also from rural Tuscany, also apprentice to another Medici favorite, Ghirlandaio. This bloke, Lorenzo in 1488 said to Ghirlandaio, I'm setting up a new art school because you recommend talented, promising young pupils. Ghirlandaio said, oh, this bloke's brilliant. And his name was Michelangelo.
他是强大国家的富有统治者，并受到了相应的对待。现在这里有个有趣的事情。我在许多关于美第奇家族的书籍中读到，1487年，奥斯曼苏丹巴耶济德二世送给他一个动物园，里面有一头狮子和一只长颈鹿，但是汤姆，就在录音前不久，你告诉我这些书搞错了。它们确实搞错了。我对这件事了如指掌，因为洛伦佐的长颈鹿是整个文艺复兴历史上最有趣的一件事。我有关于长颈鹿的大量信息。
Would you know, Dominic, I reckon if if you're the guy who talent spots Leonardo Michelangelo, I reckon you can claim to be a great patron of Renaissance art. Yeah, I think that's fair enough. Don't you think I suppose so you may be not commissioning stuff, but you're spotting people exactly like a scout. Yeah. One of those guys who's like a scout from Newcastle United who
这是一个精彩的故事。我本来想基本上劫持你的节目，对吧？就那种大大偏离正题去谈论长颈鹿。但随后你提出了一个绝妙的战术举措，即我们在加更节目中来谈这个。是的。所以这就是我们要做的。它将发布。
spotted Alan Shearer or something like that. I was thinking more kind of, you know, a manager in the 60s going into clubs and spotting the Beatles or the Rolling Stones. Okay, fair enough. Brian Epstein. Yeah. Whenever in doubt, you reach for the Beatles and I did mention the Stones as well on this. Yeah, you did. So anyway, you can see why foreign courts think of Lorenzo as a worthy peer. Basically, they see him as like them. He's not just a merchant. He's not just a banker. He's gone beyond anything that Cosimo did.
如果你是《历史的剩余》俱乐部的会员，两天后，如果你在节目刚发布时收听的话，就是这样。你将听到关于这只长颈鹿的讨论，关于文艺复兴时期动物的讨论，诸如此类。汤姆，我相信你的断言是，这将是《历史的剩余》有史以来最激动人心、最引人入胜、最轰动的节目。如果你不注册加入《历史的剩余》俱乐部并收听，restlesshistory.com，你就是疯了。好吧，公平地说。所以那是周三将要播出的长颈鹿节目。回到洛伦佐和马基雅维利。现在你提到了马基雅维利。马基雅维利对洛伦佐的评价。马基雅维利在洛伦佐去世时二十多岁。他说他深受命运和上帝的眷顾。因此，他所有的事业都取得了成功。他的生活方式、他的审慎和他的好运，被意大利国境之外的王公贵族们所熟知和钦佩。我知道我这么说很鲁莽。
He's the rich ruler of a powerful state and he's treated accordingly. So now here's an interesting thing. I read in lots of books about the Medici that in 1487, the Ottoman Sultan Bayezid II sent him a menagerie that included a lion and a giraffe, but Tom, moments before this recording, you told me that these books were mistaken. They are mistaken. And I know all about this because Lorenzo's giraffe is the single most interesting thing that happens in the entire history of the Renaissance. I have so much information about the giraffe.
我认为马基雅维利是个傻瓜。我认为他完全错了。什么？是的。难以置信的是，马基雅维利被蒙蔽了双眼，没有看清政治的现实。汤姆，你敢相信我会这么说吗？好吧，在洛伦佐活着的时候，一切都很顺利，对吧？对。我的意思是，事情会走向灾难性结局这一点并不显而易见。
It's a brilliant story. And I want essentially to hijack your episode, didn't I? Yeah. Just kind of go massively off piece and talk about giraffes. But you then suggested in an ignificent tactical maneuver that actually we do this in a bonus. Yeah. So that's what we're going to do. And it will be going out.
他是文艺复兴时期意大利的安格拉·默克尔。是的，他是。这是一个非常好的比喻。在他当政期间，一切看起来都棒极了他一离开，每个人都说：“哦，太烂了。我想吃托尼·熊（Tony bear）。”基本上，整场演出都是建立在舆论操纵和自我宣传之上的。它建立在一座债务山上。
If you are a member of the rest of the history club in two days time, if you're listening to this, when it's come out, that's right. You'll be talking about this giraffe, you'll be talking about Renaissance animals, all of that. And your claim Tom, I believe, is that this will be the most exciting, riveting and sensational episode the Restless History has ever done. If you don't sign up to the Restless History Club and listen, restlesshistory.com, you're mad. Okay, fair enough. So that's the giraffe that's coming on Wednesday. Back to Lorenzo Machiavelli. Now you mentioned Machiavelli. Machiavelli's verdict on Lorenzo. So Mach's the draft that's coming on Wednesday. Back to Lorenzo Machiavelli.
所以与他的前任们不同，洛伦佐彻底且完全地经营管理不善了美第奇银行。在他主政期间，伦敦和布鲁日的办事处双双倒闭，因为它们损失了太多的钱。例如，伦敦办事处基本上把钱借出去，把巨额资金借给了爱德华四世。正如我们之前讨论过的，爱德华四世是你最不想把巨额资金借给的人，因为他简直就是拉斯维加斯的猫王。好吧，通常英国那些叫爱德华的人都是如此。是的，没错。因为爱德华三世也曾拖垮了一大批佛罗伦萨银行。没错。
Now you mentioned Machiavelli. Machiavelli's verdict on Lorenzo. So Machiavelli is in his twenties when Lorenzo dies. He said he was loved by fortune and by God. And as a result, all his enterprises came to a successful conclusion. His way of life, his prudence and his fortune were known and admired by princes far beyond the borders of Italy. And I know this is reckless of me.
现在你提到了马基雅维利。马基雅维利对洛伦佐的评价是：洛伦佐去世时马基雅维利二十多岁。他说洛伦佐受到命运和上帝的眷顾，因此他所有的事业都取得了成功。他的生活方式、审慎和运势受到了意大利境外诸侯的了解和赞赏。我知道我这么说很大胆。
I think Machiavelli was a fool. I think he was completely wrong. What? Yes. Unbelievably Machiavelli is blind and has not seen the realities of politics. Tom, can you believe that I'm making that claim? Well, while Lorenzo is alive, everything goes well, right? Right. I mean, it's not obvious that things are going to go disastrously.
我觉得马基雅维利是个傻瓜。我觉得他完全错了。什么？是的。难以置信的是，马基雅维利竟然盲目，没有看到政治的现实。汤姆，你敢相信我竟然会这么说吗？嗯，在洛伦佐活着的时候，一切都很顺利，对吧？对的。我的意思是，事情会走向灾难并不是显而易见的。
He's the kind of the Angela Merkel of Renaissance Italy. Yes, he is. That's a very good comparison. While he's in power, everything looks brilliant. The moment he leaves, everyone says, oh, rubbish. I want to eat the Tony bear. So basically, the whole thing is based on spin and self-promotion. It's built on a mountain of debt.
他有点像文艺复兴时期意大利的安格拉·默克尔。是的，确实如此。这是一个非常好的比喻。他在位时，一切看起来都光芒四射；他一离开，每个人都说，哦，太糟糕了。基本上，这一切都建立在粉饰和自我宣传之上，是建立在债务山上的。
So unlike his predecessors, Lorenzo has totally and utterly mismanaged the Medici Bank. During his time, the offices in London and Bruges both collapsed because they had lost so much money. So for example, the London office had basically lent money, loads of money to Edward IV. And as we discussed before, Edward IV is the last man you want to lend loads of money to because he's just Elvis in Vegas. Well, generally English things called Edward. Yeah, exactly. Because Edward III had brought down a whole load of Florentine banks as well. Exactly.
因此，与他的前任不同，洛伦佐彻底且完全地经营管理不善美第奇银行。在他任职期间，伦敦和布鲁日的办事处都因亏损严重而倒闭。例如，伦敦办事处基本上把大笔资金借给了爱德华四世。正如我们之前讨论过的，爱德华四世是你最不想借钱给的人，因为他就像拉斯维加斯的猫王。嗯，通常英国叫爱德华的人都这样。是的，完全如此。因为爱德华三世也曾拖垮了一大批佛罗伦萨银行。确实如此。
The Lyon branch that runs into trouble, they have to send people from Italy to sort it out. The branches in Rome and Naples are actually losing money and then that really should not be happening. And part of the reason for this is that, whereas Cosimo had been very good at lending money, Lorenzo is really only good at one thing, which is borrowing it. He basically starts dipping into his cousin's trust funds, which he's meant to be managing. He's their guardian, and he's taking tens of thousands of Florins from their trust funds. And in 1485, they come of age and they say, we'd like our money now. And he says, oh, I don't actually have it.
里昂的分行陷入麻烦，他们必须从意大利派人去解决。罗马和那不勒斯的支行实际上在亏钱，而这本不该发生。部分原因在于，科西莫非常擅长借出资金，而洛伦佐真正擅长的只有一件事，那就是借钱。他基本上开始动用他本该负责管理的表亲们的信托基金。他是他们的监护人，却从他们的信托基金中拿走了几万弗罗林。到了1485年，他们到了法定年龄，说现在想要回他们的钱。而他说，哦，其实我没有。
Not only that, but when they were young, he had blackmailed them into lending him money and he had said, if you don't lend me like hundreds of thousands of Florians, I'll never let you have your trust funds. I mean, he'd behave very poorly. They basically file suit against him and he has to pay them off, A, with land in the Magello, so his country of states, but also he has to dip into the Florentine treasury public money to pay these guys off. so his country estates, but also he has to dip into the Florentine treasury, public money to pay these guys off.
不仅如此，在他们年轻时，他还勒索过他们向他借钱，并说过，如果你们不借给我几十万弗罗林，我永远不会让你们拿到信托基金。我的意思是，他的行为非常恶劣。他们基本上对她提起诉讼，他不得不把他们打发走，A，用穆杰洛的土地，也就是他的乡间地产，但他还必须动用佛罗伦萨国库的公款来打发这群人。所以他的乡间地产，还有他必须动用佛罗伦萨国库的公款来打发这群人。
And in her book, very caustic take on the Medici, Mary Hollingsworth basically says, he probably embezzled hundreds of thousands of Florins in public money to cover his debts. She says, Lorenzo's corruption is a sorry tale of greed and one that rarely makes it into the annals of Medici history. But I suppose again, sticking up for Lorenzo, he could have just nicked the money from his cousins and then never paid them back. To that degree, he remains subject to the law. I suppose so. Yes, I guess that's the point, isn't it? Florence is nothing like an absolute monarchy. He can't just screw money out of people and spend it without there being legal ramifications.
在她的书中，玛丽·霍灵斯沃斯对美第奇家族进行了非常尖刻的评价，她基本上说，他可能侵吞了数十万弗罗林的公款来偿还债务。她说，洛伦佐的腐败是贪婪的一个可悲故事，而且很少能进入美第奇历史的编年史。但我想再次为洛伦佐辩护的是，他本可以直接从表亲那里偷走钱，然后一去不还。在这个程度上，他仍然受法律约束。我想是的。是的，我想这正是关键所在，不是吗？佛罗伦萨一点也不像绝对君主制。他不能随心所欲地榨取人们的钱财并随意花掉，而不用承担法律后果。
No, you're absolutely right. So it's not quite Vladimir Putin's Russia or something. It's not an autocracy in that sense. Anyway, I think by the end of the 1480s, partly because of all this, you get a real sense of strain and it's partly this financial strain on him, but it's also actually physical. So his wife died in 1488, Clareice. She died of TB and she was only 38 years old. He didn't go to her funeral, but this isn't because he hated her.
不，你说得完全对。所以这不太像弗拉基米尔·普京的俄罗斯之类的地方。从这个意义上说，它不是专制政体。无论如何，我认为到1480年代末，部分由于这一切，你会感受到一种真正的紧张感，这部分是对他而言的财政压力，但实际上也是身体上的。因此，他的妻子克拉丽丝于1488年去世。她死于肺结核，年仅38岁。他没有去参加她的葬礼，但这并不是因为他恨她。
It's because he was basically had big health problems himself. So running through this family is this issue of gout. They all have terrible gout. He's also got terrible eczema and he's really suffering with it. I mean, that's not the image you have of Lorenzo, is it? Not at all. Sort of weeping sores and aching joints. That's not the magnificence I'm looking for.
这是因为他自己基本上有很大的健康问题。所以这个家族流传着痛风的问题。他们都有可怕的痛风。他还有严重的湿疹，深受其苦。我的意思是，这并不是你对洛伦佐的印象，对吧？一点也不。某种泪流满面的溃疡和疼痛的关节。这不是我寻找的宏伟气象。
No. So when he goes to the country, he has to be carried by litter because he can't walk. He just sort of lies there all the time staring at his giraffe and reading. No, he doesn't. He doesn't because his giraffe is dead by this point. Oh no the giraffe is dead! Yeah it has a tragic death which we'll come to in the bonus. Oh my god this is another trailer for your bonus episode brilliant love it.
不。所以当他去乡下时，他必须被轿子抬着，因为他不能走路。他只是整天躺在那里，盯着长颈鹿发呆并看书。不，他没有。他没有，因为他的长颈鹿此时已经死了。哦，不，长颈鹿死了！是的，它经历了一场悲惨的死亡，我们将在彩蛋中讲到。哦，天哪，这是你彩蛋节目的又一个预告片，太棒了，我喜欢。
That's terrible poor giraffe. So when people go to visit him maybe because the giraffe has died they find him very disconsolate. It's weeping. His doctor gives him important advice he says beware of cold and damp feet, has died, they find him very disconsolate. It's weeping. His doctor gives him important advice. He says, beware of cold and damp feet, beware of moonlight, beware of the air at sunset. Do not eat pears or swallow grape pips.
太可怕了，可怜的长颈鹿。所以当人们去拜访他时，也许是因为长颈鹿死了，他们发现他非常沮丧。他在哭泣。他的医生给了他重要的建议，他说当心寒冷和潮湿的脚，已经死了，他们发现他非常沮丧。他在哭泣。他的医生给了他重要的建议。他说，当心寒冷和潮湿的脚，当心月光，当心日落时的空气。不要吃梨，也不要吞咽葡萄籽。
These apparently are very bad for you if you've got gout. But if he's got to beware of cold and damp feet, I mean, he'd be fine with the feet of that hermit, wouldn't he? Yeah, you're not wrong. You know what? That hermit's really got to you. You really feel for that hermit. It's the most horrible thing I've heard, I think, in the
如果你得了痛风，这些显然对你非常不好。但如果他必须防范寒冷和潮湿的脚，我的意思是，他会对那个隐士的脚没意见，对吧？是的，你没说错。你知道吗？那个隐士真的触动了你。你真的很同情那个隐士。我认为这是我在
whole course of the rest of history. Wow. I mean, we've got seven Arola's torches to come, remember? And I think Lorenzo's physical sickness seems to mirror very pleasingly for a historian. It mirrors the sickness of the body politic. Because the same year that, you know, the doctors saying saying don't need any pairs, they have to devalue the currency, they introduce a new coin.
历史其余部分中听到的最可怕的事情。哇。我的意思是，我们还有萨佛纳罗拉的火刑柱要看，记得吗？我认为洛伦佐的身体疾病似乎对历史学家来说非常令人欣慰地反映了政治机体的疾病。因为就在医生说不要吃任何梨的那一年，他们不得不让货币贬值，他们引入了一种新硬币。
Behind this, Florence basically, everyone thinks Renaissance Florence brilliant, financially innovative, so much money, but actually it's already past its peak, partly because of us, because of the English. Because we had once sent Florence loads of our wool for them to process it and dye it. But now we're doing that ourselves. We don't need the Florentines. They're making less money, their banks are in trouble, people are going bankrupt. Just on the streets, partly because people haven't got so much money,
在此背后，佛罗伦萨基本上，每个人都认为文艺复兴时期的佛罗伦萨光芒四射、财务创新、资金雄厚，但实际上它已经过了鼎盛时期，部分原因是我们，因为英国人。因为我们曾经向佛罗伦萨发送了大量的羊毛，让他们进行加工和染色。但现在我们自己正在做这件事。我们不需要佛罗伦萨人。他们赚的钱变少了，他们的银行陷入困境，人们正在破产。就在街上，部分原因是因为人们没有那么多钱，
they're more conscious now of the Medici election rigging and of the cronyism and the corruption and so on. And it is at precisely this point, with Lorenzo ailing, with France's economy in decline, with protests beginning in the streets, and guess what? The storm clouds gathering overhead, that people start to hear this new voice that begins to cut through.
他们现在更加意识到美第奇家族的选举操纵、裙带关系和腐败等等。正是在这个时候，随着洛伦佐病入膏肓，法国经济衰退，街头抗议开始出现，你猜怎么着？乌云在头顶聚集，人们开始听到这个开始脱颖而出的新声音。
And this belongs to a Dominican friar, who for the last few years has been telling his listeners that the apocalypse, the time of the beast and of the last judgment and the last battle between Christ and Antichrist, that this apocalypse is at hand. And that man Dominic is Girolamo Savonarola and if you like heated apocalyptic rhetoric, come back after the break. Heated apocalyptic rhetoric, come back after the break. Hello, welcome back to the rest of history and Dominic, it's all kicking off in Florence now. It's all turning very, very apocalyptic, isn't it?
这属于一位多明尼加修士，在过去的几年里，他一直对听众说，末日、野兽的时代、末日审判以及基督与敌基督之间的最后之战，这个末日已经临近。那个名叫多明尼加的男人就是吉罗拉莫·萨佛纳罗拉，如果你喜欢激昂的末日修辞，中场休息后回来。激昂的末日修辞，中场休息后回来。你好，欢迎回到历史的其余部分，多明尼加，佛罗伦萨现在一切都在如火如荼地进行。一切都变得非常非常具有末日色彩，不是吗？
It is. So last time we come to Drolomo, seven Arola, and we set him up right at the beginning. He could be a forerunner of the Reformation. He could be a, um, a potential Catholic saint. He could be a kind of socialist revolutionary. That's how some people have seen him, or he could be the ultimate mad monk bent on slaughter and bloodshed. One of the great monsters of history. One of the great monsters of history, according to Simon Seabag, points of fury. So shall we find out?
确实。所以上一次我们遇到了吉罗拉莫·萨佛纳罗拉，我们在开始时就对他进行了定位。他可能是宗教改革的先驱。他可能是一个潜在的天主教圣人。他可能是一种社会主义革命者。有些人就是这样看他的，或者他可能是致力于屠杀和流血的终极疯狂僧侣。历史上的伟大怪物之一。根据西蒙·西巴格的观点，激情之点，他是历史上的伟大怪物之一。那么我们去了解一下吧？
Let's, let's start at the beginning. He's not from Florence, interestingly. He was born in Ferrara, which is about 90 miles north of Florence in 1452. He came from a professional mercantile family. He had a humanist education, so he learned Latin. He read classical poetry. He wrote sonnets and the style of Petrarch. He studied a bit of Plato, so this is the point at which Plato has really started to come in clearly. His parents are quite classical poetry. He wrote sonnets and the style of Petrarch. He studied a bit of Plato. So this is the point at which Plato has really started to come in clearly. His parents are quite pious. Later on, people said, oh, he was very religious as a boy. I think that's just a formula, sort of Saint's life formula. But he might have been. He might have been,
让我们从头开始说起。有趣的是，他不是佛罗伦萨人。他于1452年出生在费拉拉，该地位于佛罗伦萨以北约90英里处。他出身于一个职业商人家庭。他受过人文主义教育，所以他学过拉丁语。他读过古典诗歌。他用彼特拉克的风格写过十四行诗。他研究过一点柏拉图，所以这是柏拉图真正开始清晰显现的时期。他的父母相当古典诗歌。他用彼特拉克的风格写过十四行诗。他研究过一点柏拉图。所以这是柏拉图真正开始清晰显现的时期。他的父母相当虔诚。后来人们说，哦，他小时候非常宗教。我认为这只是一种公式，某种圣徒生平的公式。但他可能真的是。他可能真的是，
you don't know. I have to say, an absolutely brilliant book by an American scholar, the late Donald Weinstein on Savonarola, which basically digs behind all the myths that you see in the popular histories. And I recommend it. It's one of those books that sort of turns everything you thought on its head, which I always really enjoy. So I've depended very much on that. And I think people should check that out if they're interested in it.
你不知道。我必须说，美国学者、已故的唐纳德·温斯坦（Donald Weinstein）关于萨佛纳罗拉的一本绝对精彩的著作，基本上挖掘了你在通俗历史中所看到的所有神话背后的真相。我推荐它。这是那种颠覆你所有看法的书，我一直非常喜欢。所以我非常依赖它。如果对此感兴趣，我认为大家应该去看看。
He goes to the University of Ferrara, possibly to become a doctor. But then when he's in his late teens, he has some sort of crisis. And Weinstein thinks it probably has something to do unsurprisingly with sex. That he might've made overtures to a woman from the Strozzi banking family. And she said, no, she wasn't interested. And he just went into a massive kind of funk and depression and never really recovered. She's kind of incel. He is a bit of an incel.
他进入费拉拉大学，可能是为了成为一名医生。但当他快二十岁时，他经历了一些危机。温斯坦认为这可能毫无意外地与性有关。他可能曾向斯特罗齐银行业家族的一位女性示好。而她说不，她不感兴趣。然后他陷入了一种巨大的恐惧和抑郁中，再也没有真正恢复过来。她有点像非自愿独身者。他确实有点像非自愿独身者。
I know people sometimes roll their eyes at that and they say, well, let's try a comparison. But I think actually it's a good comparison. This sense of frustration and repression and sort of seething subterranean passion, you see that running right through his life and career. He's a very, very intense young man. And in 1472, so when he's 20, he writes a poem called On the Ruin of the World and he says, you know, I wish God would punish the world for its sins. And he's writing here about the Pope, Sixtus the Fourth, and he writes, the hand of the
我知道人们有时会对这种说法翻白眼，他们会说，好吧，让我们尝试做个比较。但我认为这确实是个好比较。这种挫折感、压抑感以及某种汹涌的潜意识激情，你可以看到它贯穿于他的整个生活和职业生涯。他是一个非常非常激进的年轻人。1472年，也就是他20岁时，他写了一首名为《论世界的毁灭》的诗，他说，你知道，我希望上帝因世界的罪恶而惩罚它。他在这里写的是教皇西克斯图斯四世，他写道，
pirate has grasped the scepter, St Peter falls to the ground. Oh, look at that catamite and that pimp robed in purple, a clown followed by the rabble adored by a blind world. Do you not scorn that lascivious pig? He pleasures himself and usurps your high praises with sycophants and parasites while your followers are exiled from country to country. I don't know who you is. I think you may there be Jesus.
海盗之手已经抓住了权杖，圣彼得倒在地上。哦，看那个身穿紫袍的男宠和皮条客，一个小丑跟随着乌贼，受到盲目世界的崇拜。难道你不鄙视那头淫荡的猪吗？他自娱自乐，用奉承者和寄生虫篡夺了你崇高的赞誉，而你的追随者却背井离乡，流亡异国。我不知道你指的是谁。我想你指的可能是耶稣。
It's hard to tell. Anyway, there's a lot going on there. He's an unhappy young man, basically. And after three years of this, of sort of staring into the middle distance thinking about girls and wrestling with lust, he decides to go to Bologna and he joins the Dominican Order. And his family were very shocked. And he writes to his father, I'm motivated by horror at, and I quote, the great misery of the world, the wickedness of men, the rapes, the adulteries, the thefts, the pride, the idolatry, the vile curses.
很难说。无论如何，那里发生了很多事情。他基本上是一个不快乐的年轻人。经过三年这样的生活，凝视着中距离思考女孩并与情欲搏击之后，他决定去博洛尼亚加入多明尼加修会。他的家人非常震惊。他给父亲写信说，我受到恐惧的驱使，引用他的话说，“世界的巨大苦难，人们的邪恶，强奸、通奸、盗窃、骄傲、偶像崇拜、恶毒的诅咒。”
So this sort of sense of a bloke who's spending an awful lot of time in his bedroom, you know, making himself very unhappy on chat groups. Yeah. I mean, absolutely runs through this. Now that might make it sound like he's retiring from the world, but the Dominicans are not one of those orders who kind of lock themselves away are they? You must know all about the Dominicans, Tom. Yeah, well, we talked about them in the series we did on the Albert Jensen crusade. They're
所以这种感觉就像是一个在卧室里花大量时间，你知道，在聊天群里让自己很不快乐的家伙。是的。我的意思是，这绝对贯穿了整个过程。现在这可能会让人觉得他正在隐退于世，但多明尼加修会并不是那种将自己锁起来的修会，对吧？你一定对多明尼加修会了如指掌，汤姆。是的，我们在关于阿尔比十字军东征的系列节目中谈到过他们。他们是
founded by Dominic, Dominicannus, the dog of the Lord, and they're going out there and they're trying to redeem heretics, those who have abandoned Christ, all of that kind of stuff. Yeah, exactly. The shock troops of the Lord. They're shock troops of the Lord, exactly. So they thrive on the margins, don't they, of Europe, but also they really start to make a name for themselves and find a place in cities and towns that have boomed, that have
由多明尼克（Dominic），多米尼坎努斯（Dominicannus，主的狗）创立的，他们走出去试图拯救异端，那些抛弃了基督的人，所有诸如此类的事情。是的，完全如此。主的突击队。他们是主的突击队，完全正确。所以在欧洲的边缘蓬勃发展，不是吗？但他们也真正开始崭露头角，在繁荣的城市和小镇中找到一席之地，这些地方
got lots of new migrants, lots of new people, but where the established church is struggling to keep up with the demand. Weinstein calls them a disciplined core of militant gospelers. So they're very militant. They're very austere often. And there's sometimes in the late 15th century, there is this kind of mystical streak as well. And all of that, you know, basically is a perfect fit for Savonarola's character. All the time he is obsessed with this issue of worldly corruption. He writes another poem called On the Ruin of the Church and he says the church itself has fallen victim to greed and lust. So you can see in that why some people say, oh, there may be the seeds of Protestantism and all this kind of
有大量的新移民，很多新面孔，但传统的教会在那里很难跟上需求。温斯坦称他们为“纪律严明的激进福音传道者核心”。所以他们非常激进。他们通常非常简朴。在15世纪末，有时也会有一种神秘的倾向。所有这一切，你知道，基本上非常符合萨佛纳罗拉的性格。他一直痴迷于世俗腐败的问题。他写了另一首名为《论教会的毁灭》的诗，他说教会本身已经成为了贪婪和色欲的牺牲品。所以你可以从中学到为什么有些人会说，哦，这其中可能存在新教的萌芽和所有这类东西。虽然当然，历史上很多人都说，哦，教会腐败了，有太多的贪婪。我认为这比这更具体。我认为这是改革教会的冲动的一部分，但更广泛地说是改革世界，自11世纪以来，这一直是拉丁西方的一个巨大的痉挛性本能。11世纪是汤姆·霍兰的宾果游戏，我们喜欢它。但这很重要，因为它是真的，因为它赋予了拉丁欧洲人民一种本能，即世界是用来改革、净化和清洗的。
stuff. Although of course, lots of people throughout history have said, oh, the church is foreign, there's too much greed. I think it's more specific than that. I think it's part of the urge to reform the church, but the world more broadly that has been a great convulsive instinct in the Latin West since at least the 11th century. The 11th century is Tom Holland bingo, we love it. But it matters because it's true, because it gives to people in Latin Europe a kind of instinct that the world is there to be reformed and purified and cleansed. Yeah, I mean, that thing about cleansing, that's totally seven a roller. The sort of dirt and corruption on the one hand and purity and virtue on the other. He really goes in for all this. Anyway, eventually in 1482, he is sent to the convent San Marco in Florence. Now some people will remember we mentioned this place a lot in the very first episode
是的，我的意思是，关于清洁的那件事，完全就是萨佛纳罗拉的风格。一方面是污垢和腐败，另一方面是纯洁和美德。他真的很热衷于所有这些。无论如何，最终在1482年，他被派往佛罗伦萨的圣马可修道院。现在有些人会记得我们在本系列的第一集中多次提到过这个地方。这很重要，因为它是一个美第奇的地方。这是科西莫在教皇的建议下修复的修道院，为了拯救他的灵魂，免得他被拖入地狱燃烧的沙子中。他把所有的钱都花在了回廊和图书馆上。这就是弗拉·安杰利科在所有修士的牢房里画下这些神秘场景的地方。
of this series. It's important because it's a Medici place. It's the monastery that Cosimo had renovated on the advice of the Pope to save his soul so that he wouldn't be dragged into the burning sand in hell. He'd spent all this money on the cloisters and on the library. This is the place that Fra Angelico had painted these mystical scenes in the cells of all the monks.
现在它是佛罗伦萨旅游日程上的顶级景点之一。这不是远离尘世的隐修所。它非常靠近市中心。它只是远离尘世的隐修所。它非常靠近市中心。它离大教堂只有几步之遥。如果你走出前门，你几乎可以看到美第奇宫，美第奇家族的圣洛伦佐教堂。即使在当时，修士们仍然依靠美第奇家族的每周汇款。人们说修士们吃的是美第奇的面包。换句话说，他正在向美第奇家族权力的核心轴线移动。他正处于佛罗伦萨的心脏地带。
Now it's one of the top attractions on the kind of Florentine tourist agenda. It's not a retreat from the world. It's very close to the center of the city. It's just a retreat from the world. It's very close to the center of the city. It's just a short walk from the cathedral. If you step out of the front door you can almost see the Medici palace, the Medici church of San Lorenzo. Even at the time the monks are still depending on weekly remittances from the Medici family. People say the monks eat the bread of the Medici. In other words, he is moving to the central kind of axis of Medici power. He's right in the heart of Florence.
现在他的工作是教导新手逻辑和哲学，坦率地说，这对我来说听起来很无聊。嗯，但是汤姆，我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？因为那里明显预示着路德，他同样是一个非常激烈的苦行僧，出人意料地放弃了另一种更世俗的职业，并成为了一名老师。那里有真正的相似之处。但当然，缺少的相似之处在于路德教授的是圣经和神学。所以他以我认为萨佛纳罗拉没有的方式参与了作为基督徒的核心所在。是的，我认为这是真的。
Now his job is to teach the novices logic and philosophy, which sounds frankly to me very boring. Well, but Dominic, I mean, it's interesting, isn't it? Because there is an obvious foreshadowing there of Luther who likewise is a very intense ascetic man who has unexpectedly given up an alternative, more secular career and who becomes a teacher. And there are real points of resemblance there. But of course, the point of resemblance that is absent is the fact that Luther is teaching scripture and theology. So he is engaging with the absolute molten core of what it is to be a Christian in a way that I think Savonarola isn't. Yeah, I think that's true.
这就是为什么他有些方面似乎预示了宗教改革，但他并没有像路德那样深入研究神学。不，他没有。我想你是绝对正确的。他根本没有。话虽如此，他确实，他得到了。我想你是绝对正确的。他根本没有。话虽如此，他确实，他得到了。
Which is why there are aspects of him that seem to prefigure the Reformation, but he doesn't dive deep into the theology in the way that Luther does. No, he doesn't. I think you're absolutely right. He doesn't at all. That said, he does, he gets't. I think you're absolutely right. He doesn't at all. That said, he does, he gets very het up. Sure, for sure.
所以我说，当他跟新手说话时，这可能非常无聊。我的意思是，他激动得哭了起来，眼泪顺着脸颊流下来。具有讽刺意味的是，他实际上做不到的是发表精彩的布道。他是个糟糕的传道人。所以他有费拉拉口音，佛罗伦萨人显然觉得这滑稽极了。他有一种非常刺耳的粗哑嗓子，大概像小罗伯特·F·肯尼迪那样。想象他那样说话。他有一种非常刺耳的嗓子，不是吗？
So I said, it might be very boring when he's speaking to the novices. I mean, he gets so excited that he starts crying and tears running down his face. What he can't actually do ironically is give a good sermon. He's a bad preacher. So he's got a Ferrara accent, which clearly people in Florence think is hilarious. And he's got a very harsh kind of croaky voice, like Robert F. Kennedy Jr., I guess. Imagine him speaking like that. He's got a very sort of rasping voice, hasn't he?
像青蛙一样。是的。所以当萨佛纳罗拉说话时，他会进行一系列的布道，过了一会儿人们就不来了。所以我本该用那种声音做那种朗读。是的，完全如此。我可能会把它留到下一集。是的，迫不及待。天哪，那会吸引人们加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部。
Like a frog. Yeah. So when Severn Arola speaks, he'll give a series of sermons and people will stop coming after a while. So I should have done that reading in a kind of voice. Yeah, exactly. I might save that up for the next episode. Yeah, can't wait. God, that'll get people joining the Restless History Club.
所以萨佛纳罗拉本人曾说：“我既没有声音，也没有气息，也没有风格。事实上，每个人都讨厌我的布道。”那么是什么改变了？他是如何成为这个出色的传道人的？答案是他找到了一个真正引起共鸣的主题。你在中场休息前提到过。他去了圣吉米尼亚诺这个小镇，另一个非常受欢迎的旅游目的地，有着可爱的塔楼，那是1485年。他深入探讨了世界的罪恶和腐败。
So Severnord himself said, I had neither voice nor breath nor style. In fact, everyone disliked my preaching. So what changes? How does he become this fantastic preacher? The answer is that he finds a theme that really resonates. And you mentioned it before the break. He goes to this town called San Gimignano, another very popular tourist destination, lovely towers in 1485. And he gets stuck into the sin and corruption of the world.
在那里，在圣吉米尼亚诺的演讲中，他发展出了这种末日风格。所以这全都是关于四骑士正在路上，战争、饥荒、瘟疫和死亡，敌基督即将来临，世界末日，等等。这方面的内容非常多。是的。我的意思是，他在这方面并不例外。
And there in the speeches he gives in San Gimignano, he develops this apocalyptic style. So it's all this stuff about the four horsemen are on their way, war, famine, plague and death, the Antichrist is coming, the end of the world, blah, blah, blah. And there is so much of this. Yeah. I mean, he's not exceptional in this.
所以约翰·希尔顿（Johann Hilton）是著名的那个人，他预测了一位改革者将在1516年到来，路德与自己联系在一起。这一切都是关于奥斯曼帝国征服意大利和德国，然后皈依，世界末日到来等等。这完全是老一套。完全如此。所以我觉得君士坦丁堡的陷落对此产生了巨大的影响。
So there's Johann Hilton is the famous one, the guy who predicts a reformer coming in 1516 that Luther associates with himself. And it's all about the Ottomans conquering Italy and Germany and then being converted and the end of the world coming and everything. It's absolutely boilerplate. Exactly. So I think the fall of Constantinople is massive in this.
我的意思是，我们距离那件事大概只有20、30年的时间。所以这真的印在人们的脑海里。当然，关于他们登陆奥特朗托的那件事，我认为它被第二件事增强了，那就是在1460年代，印刷机来到了意大利。这意味着萨佛纳罗拉成长在一个充斥着印刷版末日文本的社会中，同时也充斥着占星术的预测和预言，这本身就反映了当时的人文主义。人们对占星术非常感兴趣。
I mean, we are within what, 20, 30 years of that. So it's really on people's minds. And of course, that thing about them landing in a tranto, but it's been turbocharged, I think, by a second thing, which is in the 1460s, the printing press arrived in Italy. And that means that Savonarola has grown up in a society that is absolutely awash with printed apocalyptic texts, but also astrological predictions and prophecies, which is actually in itself reflecting the humanism of the time. People are very interested in astrology.
所以基本上无论你走到哪里，人们都在谈论10年后会发生什么。你知道，我这里有一个精彩的预测。世界末日即将来临。你知道，新闻太糟糕了。所有这类事情。你提到了约翰尼斯·希尔顿。是的。
So basically everywhere you look, people are talking about what's going to happen in 10 years time. You know, I've got a brilliant prediction here. The end of the world is coming. You know, the news is terrible. All of this kind of thing. And you mentioned Johannes Hilton. Yeah.
但佛罗伦萨也有过末日传道人的例子。实际上，在萨佛纳罗拉之前有一位先驱，名叫贝尔纳迪诺·德·费尔特雷（Bernardino de Feltre），他是一名方济各会修士。他也会发表这些攻击虚荣和奢侈的布道。他有一些关于过度性行为的非常奇怪的言论。他有一句非凡的话。他说：“女人，上帝赐予你乳房是为了哺育你的孩子，但你的乳房却在喂养男人的眼睛。”他还痴迷于鸡奸，我想我们会在适当的时候讨论这个。我们一定会讨论这个的。无论如何，这个叫贝尔纳迪诺的家伙，他组织了这些宏大的篝火晚会，虚荣的篝火晚会。
But there's been examples of apocalyptic preachers in Florence. There's actually been a forerunner to Savonarola called Bernardino de Feltre, who's a Franciscan. Now he also would give these sermons attacking lust and vanity. He's has some very strange stuff about sexual excess. He has this extraordinary line. He says, woman, God gave you breasts so you could nourish your children, but your breasts feed the eyes of men. And he's also obsessed by sodomy, which I think we'll be coming on to in due course. We will be coming on to that. Yeah. Anyway, this guy Bernardino, he organizes these great bonfires, good bonfires of the vanities.
同样，我们会回到这一点，人们在那里堆积珠宝、淫秽图片和异教书籍，某种古典书籍。他有一句你应该深思的话，汤姆。每次我们阅读奥维德，我们就在钉死基督。值得深思。是的。而且他对我们今天可能称之为同性恋时尚的东西非常敌视。每次我们阅读奥维德，我们就把基督钉在十字架上。值得深思。是的。而且他对我们今天可能称之为同性恋时尚的东西非常敌视。他是。
Again, we'll come back to this, where people will pile up jewelry and sort of lewd pictures and pagan books, kind of classical books. He has this line, which you should reflect on Tom. Each time we read Ovid, we crucified Christ. Food for thought there. Yeah. And also he's very hostile to what we might today call gay fashion. time we read Ovid, we crucified Christ. Food for thought there. Yeah. And also he's very hostile to what we might today call gay fashion. He is.
同样，我们将会谈到这一点。是的。整个时尚问题。不是这些家伙的粉丝。不，也不是利息或高利贷的粉丝。所以在1488年，这个叫贝尔纳迪诺的家伙在煽动一群男孩袭击一家犹太当铺后，实际上被赶出了佛罗伦萨。所以这里再次包含了一些非常黑暗的主题。
Yet again, we'll be coming to that. Yes. There's the whole issue of fashion. Not a fan of the chaps. No, and not a fan of interest or usury. So in 1488, he's actually kicked out of Florence, this guy Bernardino, after inciting a mob of boys to attack a Jewish porn brokers shop. So again, there's kind of some very dark themes here.
所以这意味着起初萨佛纳罗拉实际上并没有那么引人注目。你知道，他现在在做末日咆哮，他正在获得观众，但他并不罕见。因此，当1487年底他前往博洛尼亚完成学业时，没有人真正注意到。后来有人说，你会在通俗历史书中看到这种重复，哦，他被美第奇家族赶出去是因为他太让人不安了。这根本不是真的。你知道，他回去拿学位了。在接下来的几年里，他致力于自己的表演。如果你去看萨佛纳罗拉的布道，他是个个子不高的人，
So what that means is that at first Savonarola doesn't actually stand out that much. You know, he's now doing the apocalyptic ranting and he's getting an audience, but he's not unusual. So when at the end of 1487, he goes off to Bologna to finish his studies, no one really notices. It's later said, and you'll see it repeated in kind of popular history books, oh, he was kicked out by the Medici because he was so unsettling. That's just not true at all. You know, he went back to do his degree. And the next few years he works on his act. So if you went to see a Savonarola sermon, he's quite a short man,
他快四十岁了，有着巨大的黑眉毛，他最显著的特征是这个非常勾、像鸟喙一样的鼻子，而且他有一双怒视的、稍微有点疯狂的眼睛。有点凸出来，不是吗？突出的眼睛。当他站起来时，他会站起来，用这种刺耳的声音非常直白、非常激烈地说话。当时很多布道都非常学术化、错综复杂而且有点无聊。他，一点也不。有一位修士在布雷西亚听过他的演讲，
he's in his late thirties, he's got huge dark eyebrows, his defining feature is this very hooked, beaky nose and he has these glaring slightly mad eyes. Kind of bulged, don't they? Bulging eyes. When he gets up, he'll get up and in this rasping voice he speaks very plainly and very fiercely. A lot of sermons at the time are very kind of scholastic and intricate and a bit boring. He, not at all. There was a friar who heard him in Brescia
他说，我记得他说过，一场巨大的灾难即将来临意大利，特别是布雷西亚。父亲们会看到他们的孩子被可怕地杀害，并在街头被毫不留情地撕裂。人们喜欢这个，不是吗？好吧，这就是问题所在，对吧？他们觉得这很刺激。是的，这绝对是问题的关键。这里有市场。
and he said, I remember him saying that a great scourge was coming to Italy, particularly to Brescia. Fathers would see their children killed horribly and pitilessly torn apart in the streets. And people love this, don't they? Well, this is the thing, right? They find it exciting. Yeah, this is absolutely the thing. There's a market for it.
你为什么会不喜欢这个？这就像一场秀。某种恐怖电影。是的，正是如此。然后在1490年夏天，发生了看似不可思议的转折。他被邀请回到佛罗伦萨，邀请他的正是洛伦佐·德·美第奇。有些人可能会想，什么？我的意思是，他是最后一个想听到所有这些的人。
Why wouldn't you love this? It's like a show. Kind of horror film. Yeah, precisely. And then in the summer of 1490 comes what might seem an incredible twist. He is invited to go back to Florence and the man who invites him is Lorenzo de' Medici. And some people might think what? I mean he's the last person who would want to hear all this.
他怎么会对这些东西感兴趣？萨佛纳罗拉的传记作家温斯坦提出了三种可能性。他说，首先，记住我们说过洛伦佐有个叫皮科·德拉·米兰多拉的朋友。他是那种贵族人文主义知识分子。他喜欢末日预言。他就是那种贵族人文主义知识分子。他喜欢末日预言。他对这些了如指掌。他喜欢占星术。他喜欢魔法。他懂犹太教密契主义（Kabbalah），对吧？是的。
Why would he have any interest in this stuff? And Savonar and his biographer Feinstein offers three possibilities. He says first of all remember we said that Lorenzo had this mate called Pico della Merendola. He's the sort of aristocratic humanist intellectual. He loves apocalyptic prophecies. He's the sort of aristocratic humanist intellectual. He loves apocalyptic prophecies. He's all over them. He loves astrology. He loves magic. He does the Kabbalah, doesn't he? Yes.
犹太神秘主义系统，他将其引入了基督教实践中。没错。所以他可能对萨佛纳罗拉要说的话真的很感兴趣。其次，如果洛伦佐与教皇闹翻，萨佛纳罗拉对他来说可能是一个有用的人，因为他可以利用本已是教士腐败大批评者的萨佛纳罗拉来痛骂教皇，而不必自己动手。最后一个原因，实际上是一个严肃的原因，美第奇家族一直对圣马可修道院有着真正的兴趣，但它变得有点沉睡，有点，你知道，处于低谷。洛伦佐可能想把它变成一个强国，变成一个文化和精神的强国。
The Jewish mystical system and he introduces it into Christian practice. Exactly. So he's probably really interested in what Savonarola has got to say. Secondly, Savonarola might be a useful person for Lorenzo to have if he ever falls out with the pope, because he could use Savonarola, who's already a great critic of kind of clerical corruption, to slag off the pope without having to do it himself. And final reason, which is actually a serious reason, the Medici have always had a real interest in this monastery of San Marco, but it's become a little bit sleepy and a little bit kind of, you know, in the doldrums. Lorenzo probably wants to turn it into a powerhouse, into a kind of cultural and spiritual powerhouse.
他想，嗯，这家伙是个明星。这就像买了一个明星前锋之类的。我会把他带进来，你知道，很多人会来看他说话，我会看起来很好。佛罗伦萨会看起来很好。这太棒了。这再次预示了路德，不是吗？以及他与萨克森选帝侯的关系，选帝侯出于完全相同的原因赞助了路德。没错。因此，萨佛纳罗拉于1490年夏天回到佛罗伦萨。正如你所说，汤姆，他此时是个票房保证。
And he thinks, well, this guy's a star. It's like buying a star striker or something. I'll bring him in and, you know, lots of people will come and hear him talk and I'll look good. Florence will look good. It'd be brilliant. And again, such a prefiguring of Luther, isn't it? And his relationship to the Electra of Saxony, who's kind of sponsoring Luther for exactly those reasons. Exactly. So Savonarola returns to Florence in the summer of 1490. And as you said, Tom, he's great box office at this point.
所以你会去听他的布道。你知道，你可能甚至不是非常喜欢布道，但你的朋友可能会说，天哪，他讲得真好。你知道，这是令人兴奋的东西，因为他会告诉你基督大约在1500年前出生。世界即将走向终点。将会有这场巨大的危机。土耳其人和犹太人将回归真正的信仰。一切都将拉开帷幕。
So you'll go and hear one of his sermons. You know, you might not even be massively into sermons, but your friends might say, God, he's a good turn. You know, it's exciting stuff, because he will tell you Christ was born almost 1,500 years ago. The world is coming to an end. There's going to be this massive crisis. The Turks and the Jews are going to return to the true faith. It's all going to kick off.
他用一种非常激动人心的方式表达了这一点。显然公众很喜欢他。有一个来自敌对多明尼加修道院的 rival 修士，一点也不喜欢萨佛纳罗拉，他说了一句非常好的引语，他说：“战斗和许多其他事情，都充满了属灵的意义。门、墙、闪电和大地上的冰雹，他描述得如此优雅，说服了所有怀疑者，因此他的布道点燃了每个人的心。”现在有些人不喜欢它，他们嘲笑他的追随者。他们称他们为哭丧者或哭泣者，piagnoni，我认为这其中可能存在某种阶级因素。
He says it in a very exciting way. And clearly the public love him. There's a rival friar from a rival Dominican house who didn't like Severo Neruda at all, who said, it's a very good quotation actually, he said, battles and many other things, all loaded with spiritual meanings. Gates and walls and lightning bolts and hail over the earth, he described so elegantly as to persuade all doubters and thus his sermons inflamed everyone's mind. Now there are people who don't like it and they sneer at his followers. They call them the whalers or the weepers, the pianioni and the pianioni, there is a sort of class element I think possibly.
所以，被萨佛纳罗拉吸引的人是那些可能感到有点被疏离、有点被抛在后面、有点被冷落、愤怒、你知道的、以某种方式心怀不满的人，也许对美第奇政权心怀不满，染着蓝发，对环境感到焦虑，诸如此类。嗯，我想如果你是一个成功、满足、安定的局内人，你其实对所有这些东西都不感兴趣。你想去数你的钱，穿上一些中性的衣服，一边跳舞一边想着波提切利。但如果你被排斥在外，如果你满怀怨恨，如果你感到沮丧，萨佛纳罗拉的信息——
So the people who were drawn to seven, a roller are people who perhaps feel a bit alienated, they're a bit left behind, a bit left out, angry, you know, disaffected in some way, maybe disaffected from the Medici regime, blue hair, anxious about the environment, all that kind of thing. Well, I think if you're a successful, contented, settled person, you're not really interested in all this stuff. You want to go and count your money and kind of put on some androgynous clothes and caper about while thinking about Botticelli. But if you're left out of that, if you're resentful, if you're frustrated, Savonarola's message,
有朝一日富人将会燃烧——为什么这不会吸引你呢？当然会吸引你。而且通过放弃你的财富，你也可以为世界末日做好准备。如果你本来就很穷，那么你处于有利地位，不是吗？你处于有利地位。而且我认为如果存在一个我们今天实际上非常熟悉的文化战争元素，萨佛纳罗拉会攻击那些把所有时间都花在阅读和写诗上的人。那些把时间浪费在哲学上的人。他说那些阅读淫秽和猥亵材料的人，“引述：画裸体维纳斯的艺术家。”
which is that the rich will one day burn, why wouldn't that appeal to you? Of course it would appeal to you. But also that you can prepare for the end of the world by giving up your wealth. And if you're already poor, then you're in pole position, aren't you? You are in pole position. And also I think if there's a culture war element that we're actually really familiar with today, Savonarola attacks people who spend all their time reading and writing poetry. People who waste their time on philosophy. He says people who are reading lewd and obscene materials, quote, artists who paint naked venuses.
所以，我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？因为当然，那幅著名的裸体维纳斯画作是波提切利画的。是的。因为当然那幅著名的画作裸体维纳斯是波提切利画的。而且瓦萨里说波提切利成为了萨佛纳罗拉的追随者。是的。这难道不有趣吗？他还批评那些把圣母画得像妓女一样的艺术家。而且我认为波提切利的圣母画确实变得稍微不那么撩人了。
So, I mean, that's interesting, isn't it? Because of course, the famous painting of a naked Venus is by Botticelli. Yeah. Because of course the famous painting of a naked Venus is by Botticelli. And Botticelli is said by, I think by Vasari to have become a follower of Savonarola. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? He also criticises artists who paint the Virgin looking like a whore. And I think Botticelli's paintings of the Virgin do become slightly less racy.
那是错误的词。但它们变得更加庄重了，也许这是表达的方式。老实说，我绝不会把它们描述成那样。不，你是对的。但它们变得更加庄重了。它们确实变得更加庄重了。没错。那么洛伦佐对这一切作何感想？
That's the wrong word. But they become more sober perhaps is the way to put it. I would never describe them as that racy to be honest. No, you're right. But they become more sober. They do become more sober. Exactly. So what does Lorenzo make of all this?
我的意思是，他对此表示赞同。萨佛纳罗拉从未点名道姓地提到他。他基本上在做他被请来做的事。所以在接下来的两年里，他的品牌不断建立。他的修辞越来越奢侈，对性堕落的攻击越来越耸人听闻。1491年5月，他当选为圣马可修道院的院长。他开始组建团队。
I mean, he's fine with it. Savonarola never names him personally. He's basically doing what he was brought in to do. So for the next two years, his brand builds and builds. His rhetoric is ever more extravagant, sort of his attacks on sexual decadence, ever more lurid. In May, 1491, he's elected the prior of the monastery of San Marco. And he starts to build a team.
所以他有点像Goalhanger播客。随着每一次额外的百万下载量或类似的事情，他正在建立他的团队。是的。你不会想错过任何一集，对吧？不。所以你有一个叫弗拉·多梅尼科（Fra Domenico）的家伙。他将在下一集中以一种令人兴奋的激烈方式回归。他被认为是极其愚蠢的，并且相信萨佛纳罗拉告诉他的一切。
So he's a little bit like Goalhanger podcasts. He's building his team with every extra million downloads or whatever. Yeah. You don't want to miss an episode, do you? No. So you've got a bloke called Fra Domenico. He'll be coming back in the next episode in an excitingly fiery way. He's meant to be very stupid and believes everything Sefnerola tells him.
还有一个叫弗拉·西尔维斯特罗（Fra Silvestro）的人，有趣的是他在梦游时会有末日幻象。人们来看这个。人们真的相信这一点。这对萨佛纳罗拉非常有用。他说，看看这家伙。他就像在梦游一样到处走。他有各种各样的幻象。现在我们迎来了至关重要的1492年。洛伦佐现在病得很重。他不能走路。他拿不起笔。他确实有一些好消息。乔瓦尼已经16岁了。哦，所以他拿到了红衣主教的法衣。他拿到了红衣主教的法衣和帽子。对美第奇家族来说，这是一件大事，因为汤姆，乔瓦尼将成为教皇利奥十世。
And a man called Fra Silvestro, who interestingly has apocalyptic visions while sleepwalking. People come and watch that. People really believe that. And it's very useful to Sefnerola. He says, look at this bloke. He's like sleepwalking around. He's having all kinds of visions. So now we reach the crucial year of 1492. Lorenzo is now very ill. He can't walk. He can't hold a pen. He does have some good news. Giovanni has turned 16. Oh, so he gets his Cardinals robes. He gets his Cardinals robes and hats. Now this is a big deal for the Medici because Tom Giovanni will become Pope Leo X.
所以是路德的朋友。没错。路德的伟大对头。事情是这样的。乔瓦尼以一种非常美第奇的方式决定重建圣彼得大教堂，他是通过兜售赎罪券来做到这一点的。正是这一点激怒了路德，并开启了宗教改革。难以置信。
So Luther's pal. Right. Luther's great antagonist. And here's the thing. It's Giovanni who in a very Medici way decides he wants to rebuild St. Peter's and he does this by flocking indulgences. This is what drives Luther into a rage and kickstarts the reformation. Unbelievable.
非常美第奇。非常美第奇。那个四旬斋，萨佛纳罗拉在美第奇家族自己的圣洛伦佐教堂里讲道。他正处于绝对的末日狂热中，达到了他状态的巅峰。第五个时代即将来临，他说。第五位天使即将吹响号角，宣布教会的苦难。这是可怕野兽的时代。他对佛罗伦萨人民说，听着，这是做决定的时候了。
Very Medici. Very Medici. That lent, Savonarola preaches in the Medici's own church of San Lorenzo. And he's in an absolute apocalyptic frenzy is at the height of his form. The fifth age is approaching, he says. The fifth angel is about to blow his trumpet announcing the tribulations of the church. This is the time of the terrible beast. And he says to the people of Florence, look, it's make your mind up time.
要么你们现在忏悔并过上美德的生活，要么，我引述：“街头将血流成河。”那是四旬斋期间。现在我们进入四月初。洛伦佐已被转移到乡下。他现在病情确实非常严重。他肾功能衰竭。他持续发烧。
Either you repent now and need virtuous lives or and I quote, the streets will run with blood. So that's at Lent. Now we move to the beginning of April. Lorenzo has been moved to the countryside. He's now very ill indeed. He's got kidney failure. He's got constant fever.
他的医生们，我不认为他们在让情况变好。他们给他的药是碎珍珠和宝石的混合物，这同样非常美第奇，但我不认为这，这并不管用。来自城市的报告非常糟糕。预兆显示，城市的两只狮子，共和国的象征，互相攻击，其中一只被咬得太惨，以至于在4月5日星期四，毫无征兆地被安乐死了。
His doctors, I don't think they're making it better. They're giving him as medicine, a mixture of crushed pearls and precious stones, which again is very Medici, but I don't think it's, it's not efficacious. There are terrible reports from the city. Omens, the two lions of the city, the symbols of the Republic have turned on one another and one of them was so badly mauled that it had to be put down on Thursday, the 5th of April, out of nowhere.
我真心相信这件事发生了，闪电击中了佛罗伦萨大教堂的灯笼。一块巨石轰然落入广场，洛伦佐听到后说，它落在哪一边了？他们把他的方向转过去，他说，哦，不，那是离我家最近的那一边。我死定了。第二天，4月6日星期五，三个人造访了洛伦佐的床头。其中一个是他的
I genuinely believe this happened, lightning struck the lantern of Florence Cathedral. A great stone came crashing into the square and Lorenzo, when he hears it, says, which side did it fall on? They turn him the side and he says, oh no, that's the side nearest my house. I'm a dead man. The next day, Friday the 6th, three men visit Lorenzo's bedside. One of them is his
儿子皮耶罗。他软弱、自以为是、傲慢，但他作为家族之首的继承人。而且他才20岁，对吧？他才20岁。第二个是哲学家皮科·德拉·米兰多拉，热爱一点魔法和占星术。第三个，是萨佛纳罗拉。后来有传言说，萨佛纳罗拉向洛伦佐提出了三个问题。你信上帝并为你的罪孽忏悔吗？是的。你愿意放弃你靠不正当手段获得的财富
son, Piero. He's weak, he's entitled, he's arrogant, but he's the successor as head of the family. And he's only 20, right? He's only 20. The second is that philosopher Pico della Mirandola, loves a bit of magic and astrology. And the third, it's Savonarola. And it's later said that Savonarola asked Lorenzo three questions. Do you believe in God and repent of your sins? Yes. Will you renounce your ill-gotten wealth
并归还被错误夺走的东西吗？洛伦佐说，是的。你愿意恢复佛罗伦萨的自由吗？洛伦佐扭过头去，没有回答，没有给出答复。这是真的吗？你知道吗？不，根本没有发生。
and restore what's been wrongfully taken? Yes, says Lorenzo. Will you restore the liberties of Florence? Lorenzo turns his head away and doesn't answer, doesn't give a reply. Is this true? Do you know what? No, didn't happen't answer. Doesn't give a reply. Is this true? Do you know what? No, didn't happen at all.
并归还被非法拿走的东西吗？洛伦佐回答说：是的。你会恢复佛罗伦萨的自由吗？洛伦佐扭过头去，没有回答，没有给予回应。这是真的吗？你知道吗？不，根本没有发生。
Oh, totally made up. There's a humanist there. Lorenzo's mate, Poliziano, he wrote about the meeting straight afterwards. He doesn't mention this at all. He just says they prayed together and like Savonarola gave him his blessing and then went away again. Oh, how disappointing. It is disappointing.
哦，完全是编造的。那里有个威尼斯人文主义者，洛伦佐的朋友波利齐亚诺，他在事后立刻写下了关于这次会面的文章。他根本没提到这个。他只是说他们一起祈祷了，萨沃纳罗拉给了他祝福然后就走了。哦，真令人失望。确实很失望。
But Savonarola clearly is in a great kind of state because two days later on the Sunday the 8th he gives his most apocalyptic sermon yet. He says, I have seen a hand in the sky holding a sword and the sword had an inscription, the sword of the Lord over the earth swiftly and soon. Everyone's like, what's that mean? That evening, that very evening, Lorenzo the magnificent lapses into a coma. The priests hold a crucifix to his lips and he kisses it, but then his breathing slows and he dies. And his doctor, faced with the wreckage of his medicine goes out and throws himself down
但萨沃纳罗拉显然处于一种极好的状态，因为两天后的周日，即8日，他发表了他迄今为止最末世论的布道。他说，我看到天空中有一只手握着一把剑，剑上有铭文，主之剑迅速而猛烈地临到大地。每个人都在想，那是什么意思？那天晚上，就在那天晚上，伟大的洛伦佐陷入了昏迷。神父们把十字架举到他的嘴唇边，他亲吻了十字架，但接着他的呼吸变慢，然后去世了。他的医生面对着他那束手无策的药物，走了出去，把自己扔向了
a well and dies. Is that true? Yeah, that is true. Apparently that doesn't sound true. I think that's totally true. Yeah. Piero Leone. Every single book describes that happening. I'm not going to argue with the scholars of the Renaissance, Tom. So two days later, Lorenzo is buried in the Medici Church of San Lorenzo next to his brother Giovanni, who had been murdered in the Pazzi conspiracy. There are crowds in the streets. The bells are tolling. People are watching in silence. That night, Tom, people see bolts of flame in the sky. They hear wolves howling in the night. Again, I don't believe that. That's lifted from Virgil. At the church of Santa Maria Novella, a woman became possessed. She shrieked out that a bull with horns of fire was about to burn down the city.
一口井里死了。那是真的吗？是的，那是真的。显然那听起来不像是真的。我觉得那是完全真的。是的。皮耶罗·莱昂内。每一本书都描述了这件事的发生。我不会跟文艺复兴时期的学者争论，汤姆。所以两天后，洛伦佐被安葬在圣洛伦佐的梅迪奇家族教堂里，紧邻他在帕齐阴谋中被谋杀的兄弟乔瓦尼。街上挤满了人。钟声在敲响。人们默默地看着。那天晚上，汤姆，人们看到天空中划过火焰，听到狼在夜里嚎叫。再说一次，我不相信那个。那是从维吉尔那里抄来的。在圣母玛利亚诺韦拉教堂，一个女人着魔了。她尖叫着说，一头长着火角的公牛即将烧毁这座城市。
And then a week later on Good Friday, Savonarolo tells the congregation in San Lorenzo where Lorenzo has been buried, he says he's had an amazing, extraordinary vision. He saw a black cross stretching out its arms to cover the earth. And on this cross were written the words Crooks Eri Dei, the Crocs of the wrath of God. The sky was pitch black, lit by flickers of lightning, thunder roared and a great storm of wind and hail storms killed a host of people but then he saw the sky clear and a cross rising from the center of Jerusalem and on this cross the words were written the cross of the mercy of god and all nations flocked to adore it
然后一周后的耶稣受难日，萨沃纳罗拉在洛伦佐被安葬的圣洛伦佐教堂对会众说，他有了一个惊人的、非凡的幻象。他看到一个黑色的十字架伸出双臂覆盖了大地。这个十字架上写着“上帝愤怒的十字架”几个字。天空一片漆黑，闪烁的电光照亮了四周，雷声轰鸣，狂风和冰雹交加，夺去了许多人的生命，但随后他看到天空放晴，一个十字架从耶路撒冷中心升起，十字架上写着“上帝慈悲的十字架”，所有国家都蜂拥而至去朝拜它。
i mean it's thrilling stuff isn't it course very thrilling you can see why it's box office totally but tom what's it mean and what does God have in store for the people of Florence? Well we will find out next time when, and spoiler alert here, the story gets stranger, darker, madder and of course bloodier. And this is very exciting for me because it's the first thing I did for my history A level. No way. The French invasion of Italy. Savonarola becomes the master of Florence. You get bonfires blazing in the city squares and of course all the while the end of the world is approaching and Dominic members of our own apocalyptic order can hear that episode
我的意思是，这真是扣人心弦，不是吗？当然非常扣人心弦，你能看出为什么它大受欢迎。完全是这样，但汤姆，这意味着什么？上帝为佛罗伦萨人民准备了什么？好吧，我们下次就会知道了，这里有个剧透，故事变得更加诡异、黑暗、疯狂，当然也更加血腥。这对我来说非常兴奋，因为这是我为历史高级水平考试做的第一件事。不会吧。法国入侵意大利。萨沃纳罗拉成为佛罗伦萨的主人。城市广场上燃起篝火，当然与此同时，世界末日正在逼近，我们自己的末日秩序的骨干成员可以收听那一集
right now and on Wednesday of course they'll be able to hear the exciting episode we're doing on the Medici giraffe the only way you can hear about that and if you would like to hear the next episode and their episode about the Medici giraffe and you're not a member of the Restless History Club then you can go to therestlesshistory.com and sign up there so thank you Dominic thank you everyone for listening bye bye Grazie Arri arrivederci. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes?
就在现在，当然在周三，他们将能够听到我们正在制作的关于美第奇长颈鹿的精彩一集，这是你唯一能听到那个故事的方法。如果你想听下一集以及他们关于美第奇长颈鹿的那一集，而且你不是“历史余烬”俱乐部的会员，那么你可以去 therestlesshistory.com 那里注册。所以谢谢你，多米尼克，谢谢大家收听，再见，再见。大家好，你们还在这里。就在这一集的最后，我对你们的执着印象深刻。但是听着，我有个问题要问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？
And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course only one way to find out what that would be like.
你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我的品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你这么想过，当然只有一种方法可以知道那会是什么样的。
You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC Premier or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand,
你可以打断广告的进行。你可以成为下一个汇丰卓越理财或在《历史余烬》上做过广告的许多其他出色的公司。通过在《历史余烬》以及Goalhanger网络的其他节目上投放广告，你可以将你的品牌展现在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道Goalhanger网络是什么。Goalhanger正是这个节目的幕后公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，
Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest, or indeed your company's interest, by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Goalhanger 会很乐意听到你的消息。你可以立即访问 Goalhanger.com 注册你的兴趣，或者你的公司的兴趣。这就是 Goal (G-O-A-L)，Hangar (H-A-N-G-E-R)，点 com。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。